data generated by companies and
individuals like us has grown massively
over the past decade as per statista.com
the global data generated and consumed
would reach 181 zabt by
2025 organizations need to gather and
analyze such large volumes of data and
look at their past business performances
as well as results and use that
information to prepare for the future
that essentially is data analytics so
hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video tutorial of data analytics full
course 2022 by simply learn this video
will help you gain all the necessary
skills and knowledge within 12 hours to
become a data analyst in
2022 our experienced trainers will take
you through the course but before we
begin if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us so let's look at the topics we'll be
learning in this
video we'll start by understanding the
basics of data analytics and learn the
top 10 data analyst skills for
2022 after that we learned the top 10
data analysis tools followed by looking
at a use case
python next you'll get an idea of how to
manipulate and visualize data using our
packages and then look at time series
analysis INR then we'll shift our Focus
to understanding data analytics using
Excel pivot tables and learn to create
Excel dashboards moving further you'll
see some interesting data analytics
projects related to Corona virus Spotify
World happiness report and Olympics
finally we will learn some of the
important questions that are asked
frequently in data analytics interviews
so let's get started hi guys welcome to
another video tutorial by simply Loan in
today's session we will look at data
analytics for
beginners but before we begin make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never Mission
update in this video we will discuss
what data analytics is and the need for
data
analytics then we will look at the
different ways in which data analytics
can be used for followed by the various
steps involved in the data analytics
process after that we will get an idea
about the different tools used in data
analytics and the compan is using data
analytics moving forward we will see a
case study on how Walmart uses data
analytics for beta customer service and
finally we will perform a regression
analysis in R to predict sales based on
the advertising expenditure from three
mediums tv ads radio ads and newspaper
advertisements
so what is data
analytics companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour this data could be in the form of
log files web server and transactional
data as well as various customer related
data also data is being generated at a
rapid rate from social media websites
and applications such as Facebook
Instagram Twitter and
WhatsApp companies want to use this dat
to derive value out of it and make
business
decisions that's where data analytics
comes into
use data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen Trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business
predictions data analytics improves the
speed and efficiency of your
business a few years ago a business
would have gathered information manually
performed stat statistical and complex
analytics and Unearthed information that
could be used for future
decisions but today that business can
identify insights on the Fly for
immediate
decisions most organizations have big
data and many understand the need to
harness that data and extract value out
of it so they use a lot of modern tools
and Technologies to perform data
analytics some of the tools I will
discuss in detail later in this
tutorial
now that we have looked at at what data
analytics really is let us understand
the ways in which you can use data
analytics first is improved decision
making data analytics eliminates a lot
of guesswork and manual tasks from
choosing the right content planning
marketing campaigns and developing
products organizations can use the
insights they gain from data analytics
to make informed decisions leading to
better outcomes and customer
satisfaction it gives you a 360° view of
your customers which helps you
understand the behavior completely
enabling you to better meet their
needs second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to tailor customer service
to their needs provide more
personalization and build stronger
relationships with them your data can
reveal information about your customers
communication preferences their interest
their concerns and more it helps you
give better recommendations for products
and
services next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production when you have an improved
understanding of what your audience
wants you waste less time in creating
ads and content that don't match your
audience interests this helps you
optimize your campaigns create better
content strategies and hence improve
results and finally we have effective
marketing when you understand your
audience better you can Market to them
more effectively data analytics also
gives you useful insights into how your
campaigns are performing so that you can
find- tune them for optimal
outcomes you also find out the probable
customers who are the most likely to
interact with a campaign and convert
into
leads now let's discuss the various
steps involved in the data analytics
process as you can see on the screen
there are five process steps now let me
make you understand each of this one by
one so the first step is to understand
the
problem before starting with the
analysis you need to understand the
business problem and Define your goals
asking questions at the outlet is vital
because this would address issues such
as how can we reduce production costs
without sacrificing quality what are
some of the ways to increase sales
opportunities with our current
resources do customers view your brand
in a favorable way answers to these
questions will help you build a clear
road map with lucrative Solutions also
try to find out the key performance
indicators and consider the Matrix to
track along the
way the second step in the process is
data
collection after you have finalized Iz
your goals it's time to start looking
for your data data collection is the
process of gathering information on
targeted variables identified as data
requirements the emphasis is on ensuring
accurate and right data is collected
data collection starts with primary
sources which are also known as internal
sources this is typically structured
data gathered from CRM software Erp
systems marketing automation tools and
others these sources contain information
about customers finan
gaps in sales Etc under external sources
you have both structured and
unstructured data so if you're looking
to perform a sentiment analysis towards
your brand you would gather data from
various review websites or social media
apps the next step is to clean the
data the data which is collected from
various sources is highly likely to
contain incomplete duplicate and missing
values so you need to clean these
unwanted redundant data to make it ready
for analysis so to generate accurate
results analytics professionals must
identify duplicate and anomalous data
and other inconsistencies that could
skew the analysis according to a report
60% of data scientists say most of the
time is spent cleaning the data while
57% of data scientists say it's their
least enjoyable
task now the fourth step in the process
is data exploration and Analysis
once data is cleaned and ready you can
go ahead and explore the data using data
visualization and business intelligence
tools you can also use various Data
Mining and predictive modeling
techniques to analyze the data and build
models you can use different supervised
and unsupervised algorithms such as
linear regression logistic regression
decision tree KNN K means clustering and
lots more to build prediction models for
making business decisions
and the final step is to interpret the
results this part is important because
it's how a business will gain actual
value from the previous four
steps interpreting the results will help
you find unseen Trends and patterns in
the data and gain insights you can have
a validation check if the results are
answering your questions these results
can be shown to your clients and
stakeholders for better understanding
and business
collaboration
now that we have looked at the various
steps involved in data analytics let's
now see the different tools that can be
used to perform the ABB
steps so as you can see we have seven
tools including a few programming
languages that will help you perform
analytics better now let's discuss them
one by
one first we have
python python is an objectoriented open-
Source programming language that
supports a range of liaries for data
manipulation data visualization and data
modeling python programmers have
developed tons of free and open source
libraries that you can use you can find
many of them via the python package
index which is
pypi the repository of python
software python provides the default
package installer called pip or pip
Python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
Time series then you have scipi for
Technical and scientific computations it
also provides psychic learn which is a
machine learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it also has P
torch and tensorflow for deep
learning up next we have
r r is an open source programming
language majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis it provides a range
of libraries for data analysis and
visualization some of these libraries at
ggplot tidos plotly deer and
carrot then we have tblo tblo is a
popular data visualization and analytics
tools that helps you create a range of
visualizations to interactively present
the data build reports and dashboards to
Showcase insights and Trends it can
connect with multiple data sources and
give hidden business insights and
patterns then we have a competitor of
Tableau which is powerbi
powerbi is a business intelligence tool
developed by Microsoft that has an easy
drag and draw functionality and supports
multiple data sources with features that
make data visually appealing powerbi
supports features that help you ask
questions to your data and get immediate
insights you can also forecast your data
for predicting future
Trends so the next tool is Click
view click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision
making it provides social media
Discovery and interactive guided
analytics it can manipulate huge data
sets instantly with
accuracy up next we have Apache
spark Apache spark is an open source
data analytics engine to process data in
real time and Carry Out complex
analytics using SQL queries and machine
learning algorithms
it supports spark streaming for realtime
analytics and Spark SQL for writing SQL
queries it also has spark MLB which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms and then it has
graphics for graphical
computation and finally we have
SAS SAS is a statistical analysis
software that can help you perform
Analytics visualiz your data write SQL
queries perform statistical analysis and
build machine learning models to make
future predictions SAS empowers our
customers to move the world forward by
transforming data into
intelligence SAS is investing a lot to
drive software Innovation for analytics
Gartner has positioned SAS as a magic
quadrant leader for data science and
machine
learning moving on to the applications
of data
analytics data analytics is being used
in almost every sector of business these
days let's discuss a few of
them first we have
retail customers expect retailers to
understand exactly what they need and
when they need it data analytics helps
retailers meet those
demands retailers not only have an
in-depth understanding of their
customers but they can also predict
Trends recommend new products and boost
profit
ability retailers create assortments
based on customer preferences invoke the
most relevant engagement strategy for
each customer optimize supply chain and
Retail operations at every step of the
customer
Journey the second application is on
Healthcare Healthcare Industries analyze
patient data to provide life-saving
diagnosis and treatment
options they also deal with healthcare
plans and insurance information to drive
key inside sites using analytics they
can discover new drugs and come up with
new drug development
methods Advanced analytics allows
healthcare companies to improve patient
outcomes and
experience cancer cells and diabetic
retinopathy can be discovered using
Medical
Imaging at number three we have
manufacturing for manufacturers solving
problem is nothing new they fight with
difficult problems and situations on a
daily basis
from complex Supply chains to motion
applications to labor constraints and
Equipment breakdowns they deal with such
problems on a regular basis using data
analytics manufacturing sectors can
discover new cost saving and revenue
opportunities the fourth application is
related to the banking
sector Banking and financial
institutions collect vast volumes of
structured and unstructured data to
derive analytical insights and make
sound financial decisions using
analytics they can find out probable
loan defaulters customer chout rate and
detect fraudulent transactions
immediately the final application is
based on
Logistics logistics companies use data
analytics to develop new business models
that can ease their business and improve
productivity they can optimize routes to
ensure delivery reaches on time in a
cost-efficient manner they also focus on
improving order processing capabilities
as well as Performance
Management with that now let's look at
the companies using data analytics on a
daily
basis so we have the e-commerce giant
Amazon then we have Accenture followed
by the American healthcare service
organization
siga then we have the American supplier
of Health Information Technology
Solutions Services devices and Hardware
serner followed by Target and Antivirus
company
macafe NeXT we have Rapido which is an
Indian bike rental company based in
Bangalore after that we have Flipkart
and the world's largest retail company
Walmart so Sky a limit on what you use
it for let's take a look at types of
data
analytics and this can be broken up in
so many ways uh but we're going to start
with looking at the most basic questions
that you're going to be asking in data
analytics and the first one is you want
descriptive analytics what has happened
hindsight uh how many cells per call
ratio coming out of the call center if
we have 500 tourist in a forest and you
have a certain temperature how many
fires were started how many times did
the police have to show up to certain
houses um all that's descriptive the
next one is predictive Predictive
Analytics is what will happen happen
next we want to predict uh this is great
if you want have a ice cream store and
you want to predict how many people to
work at the ice cream store in a certain
day based on the temperature coming up
in the time of the year and then one of
the biggest growing and most important
parts of the industry is now
prescriptive analytics and you can think
of that as combining the first two we
have descriptive and we have predictive
then you get
prescriptive analytics how can we make
it happen foresight what can we change
to make this work
better in all the industries we looked
at before we can start asking questions
uh especially in City development
there's a good one if we want to have
our city generate more income and we
want that income to be commercial based
uh what kind of commercial buildings do
we need to build in that area that are
going to bring people over do we need
huge warehouse sales Costco sales
buildings or do we need little mom pod
joints that are going to bring in uh
people from the country to come shop
there or do you want an industrial setup
what do you need to bring that IND
industry in there is there car industry
available in that area uh if it's not a
car industry what other Industries are
in that area all those things are
prescriptive we're guessing we're
guessing what can we do to fix it what
can we do to fix crime in area with
education what kind of education are we
going to use to help people understand
what's going on so that we lower the
rate of crime and we help our
communities grow better
that's all prescriptive it's all
guessing we went foresight into how can
we make it happen how can we make this
better and we really can't not go into
enough detail on these three because a
lot of people stumble on this when they
come in and are doing analytics whether
you're the manager shareholder or the
data scientist coming in you really need
to understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past uh here we go into pred
Predictive Analytics predicting the
total units that would sell and the
profit we can expect in the future gear
up for how many employees we need how
much money we're going to make and
prescriptive analytics finding ways to
improve the sales and the profit so we
can uh sell maybe a different kind of
furniture uh we're going to guess at
what the area is looking for and how
that marketing is going to change hello
everyone we welcome you all to this
video by simply learn in today's session
we will learn a really interesting topic
that is the top skills to become a data
analyst in
2022 in today's Digital World data is
being generated by companies and
individuals every second so the role of
a data analyst holds supreme
importance so if you're looking for a
career in data analytics this video will
help you learn what a data analyst does
and the various skills you need to
possess to become a data analyst in
2022 before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learn Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from
us let's look at the agenda for this
video first we will understand who a
data analyst is then we will understand
the top 10 data analyst skills for 2022
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the company's hiring data analysts so
now let's understand who is the data
analyst a data analyst is a professional
who collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to
extract insights and useful information
from it they acquire data from primary
or secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business
problem now with this basic
understanding of who a data analyst is
let's learn the top 10 data analyst
skills for
2022 at number one we have structured
query language or SQL SQL is a top skill
that every data analyst should have data
analysts use SQL commands and functions
to store process analyze and manipulate
structured data using relational and
nosql
databases they also build data models
and write complex SQL queries and
scripts to gather and extract
information from several databases and
data
warehouses some of the popular databases
a data analyst should be familiar with
are Microsoft SQL Server MySQL postr SQL
and ibmdb 2 the second important skill
for a data analyst is Microsoft
Excel Microsoft Excel is one of the most
popular and oldest spreadsheet
applications for creating reports
performing calculations and analyzing
data data analysts need to know know how
to handle tabular data in Excel so they
should be aware of features like sorting
filtering conditional formatting pivot
tables wtif analysis and functions such
as sums and
countifs the third crucial data analy
skill for 2022 is data cleaning and
wrangling usually the data collected by
analysts from various heterogeneous
sources is often messy and contains a
lot of missing
values so it is always crucial to clean
the data and remove noise missing or
erroneous
elements it is also important to format
data using tools and methods before
using it for analysis they're
responsible for data mining as well the
data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are Excel power query and open
refine the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and
statistics data and lists often work on
data for higher Dimensions that are
greater than three in order to interpret
such data they need to be good at linear
algebra and calculus they also buil
predictive models and statistical models
such as linear regression logistic
regression knife base and K means
clustering in order to understand the
working of these algorithms they must
have knowledge about statistics and
probability coming to the fifth
important skill for a data analyst in
202 two we have programming data
analysts need to master at least one
programming language preferably python
or R in order to work with complex
business problems analysts need to write
scripts and userdefined functions to
automate tedious tasks Python and art
language provide a collection of
different libraries and packages such as
numai pandas DLI matplot lib ggplot
which data analyst can use to discover
Trends and patterns from complex data
sets
after this we have data visualization as
our sixth skill another data analyst job
role is to visualize large volumes of
data and prepare summary reports and
dashboards for the leadership team and
clients so that they can make timely
business
decisions to do this data analysts use
various data visualization tools such as
powerbi tblo and click
View using these tools data analyst can
integrate various data sets apply joint
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs the seventh skill for
a data analyst is industry
knowledge data analysts should have good
knowledge and understanding of the
industry or domain they are working in
for example if you're working in a
healthcare domain you need to know how
Healthcare analytics can be applied to
improve patient care you should have
knowledge about the challenges faced in
healthcare and how you can leverage data
and analytics to solve the issues ose
only if you have strong industry
knowledge can you try to improve the
business the eighth skill that is
important for a data and list in 2022 is
problem
solving a business deals with several
problems on a daily basis data analysts
should be ready to face those challenges
data analysts are expected to use their
problem solving skills work with the
team troubleshoot what went wrong and
provide an effective solution via data
analyst
is a data analyst with good problem
solving skills can help a business
identify current and potential issues
and determine a viable solution based on
the data it
collects the ninth skill on our list is
analytical thinking data analysts need
analytical thinking ability to break
down a complex problem into simple
components and resolve these components
one by one it is a must-have skill for
data and lists analytical thinking
includes deciding the parameters that
need to be considered for defining data
sets analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies coming to the 10th skill
among the top 10 skills for a data
analyst in 2022 we have
communication data analysts don't just
interact with computers and programs
they also interact with team members
stakeholders and data
suppliers so good communication skills
are essential data analysts also present
their findings in front of an audience
who might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms so
those were the top 10 skills a data
analyst needs to possess in 2022 do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comment
section
below now let's look at the salary of a
data an list according to glaso the
average annual Sal salary for a data
analyst in the United States is
$699,500 rupees per ROM finally let's
look at the top companies that are
hiring data analysts in
2022 here we have the consultancy and
big four Giant deoe and the
pharmaceutical company serner
Corporation then we have the tech giant
IBM retail company Walmart and the
e-commerce leader Amazon
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session after extensive research we
have come up with these top 10 data
analysis tools here we will look at the
features of each of these tools and the
companies using them so let's let's
start
off at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel
all of us would have used Microsoft
Excel at some point right it is easy to
use and one of the best tools for data
analysis developed by Microsoft Excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
Excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formula it is one of the widely
used tools be it in a small or large
setup the inter of Microsoft Excel looks
like
this let's now move on to the features
of
excel firstly Excel works
with the windows version of excel
supports programming through Microsoft's
Visual Basic for applications
VBA programming with VBA allows
spreadsheet manipulation that is
difficult with standard spreadsheet
techniques in addition to this the user
can automate tasks such as format or
data organization in
VBA one of the biggest benefits of excel
is its ability to organize large amounts
of data into orderly logical
spreadsheets and charts by doing so it's
a lot easier to analyze data especially
while creating graphs and other visual
data representations the visualization
can be generated from specified group of
cells those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel let's now have a look at
the companies using it most most of the
organizations today use Excel few of
them that use it for analysis are the UK
based company Ernest and Young then we
have Urban Pro wh Pro and
Amazon moving on to our next data
analysis tool at number nine we have
rapid
Miner a data science software platform
rapid Miner provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning learning it is used in almost
every business and Commercial sector
rapid Miner also supports all the steps
of the machine learning
process seen on your screens is the
interface of Rapid
minor moving on to the features of Rapid
minor firstly it offers the ability to
drag and drop it is very convenient to
just drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapid Miner allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision-making and formulation of
strategies it has data exploration
features such as graphs descriptive
statistics and visualization which
allows users to get valuable
insights it also has more than 1,500
operators for every data transformation
and Analysis
task let's now have a look at the
companies using rapid Miner we have the
Caribbean Airline leward Islands Air
transport next we have the United Health
Group the American online payment
company PayPal and the Australian
Telecom company mobilecon so that was
all about rapid Miner now let's see
which tool we have at number
eight we have talent at number eight
Talent is an OP Source software platform
which offers data integration and
management it specializes in Big Data
integration ation Talent is available
both in open- source and premium
versions it is one of the best tools for
cloud computing and Big Data
integration the interface of talent is
as seen on your
screens moving on to the features of
talent firstly automation is one of the
great Boon Talent offers it even
maintains the tasks for the users this
helps with quick deployment and
development it also offers open- Source
tools Talon lets you download these
tools for free the development costs
reduce significantly as the process is
gradually speed
up Talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases SAS and other Technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and Cloud apps 10
times
faster those were the features of talent
the companies using Talent are Air
France L'Oreal Cap Gemini and the
American multinational pizza restaurant
chain
dominoes next on the list at seven we
have n constant information minor on N
is a free and open- Source data
analytics reporting and integration
platform it can integrate various
components for machine learning and data
mining through its modular data
pipelining concept nime has been used in
phac ceutical research and other areas
like CRM customer data analysis business
intelligence text Mining and financial
data
analysis here is how the interface of n
application looks
like now coming to the nine
features nine provides an interactive
graphical user interface to create
visual workflows using the drag and drop
feature use of jdbc allows assembly of
nodes blending different data sources
including pre-processing such as ETL
that is extraction transformation
loading for modeling data analysis and
visualization with minimal
programming it supports multi-threaded
inmemory data processing Nim allows
users to visually create data flows
selectively execute some or all analysis
steps and later inspect the results
models and interactive
views Nim server automates workflow
execution and supports team based
collaboration ation n integrates various
other open source projects such as
machine learning algorithms from Becca
hed2 Caris Park and our project n allows
analysis of 300 million custom addresses
20 million cell images and 10 million
molecular
structures some of the companies hiring
for n are United Health Group asml
fractal analytics atos and LEGO Group
let's now move on to the next tool we
have SAS at number six
SAS facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns as you can see on your
screens this is how the interface looks
like moving on to the features of
SAS using SAS better analysis of data is
achieved by using using automatic code
generation and SAS SQL SAS allows you to
access through Microsoft Office by
letting you create reports using it and
by Distributing them through
it SAS helps with an easy understanding
of complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and
reports let's now have a look at the
companies using SAS we have companies
like genpact iqa Accenture and IBM to
name a
few that that was all about SAS so for
all those who joined in late let me just
quickly repeat our list at number 10 we
have Microsoft Excel then at number nine
we have rapid minor at number eight we
have talent at number seven we have nine
and at number six we have SAS so far do
you all agree with this list let us know
in the comment section below let's now
move on to the next five Tools in our
list
so at number five we have both R and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth
position R is a programming language
which is used for analysis as well it
has traditionally been used in academics
and research python is a highlevel
programming language which has a python
data analysis Library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from Excel spreadsheets to processing
them for
analysis this is the interface of
R next up is the interface of the Python
Jupiter
notebook let's now move on to the
features of both R and
python when it comes to the availability
of R and python it is very easy both R
and python are completely free hence it
can be used without any
license R used to compute everything in
memory and hence the computations were
limited but now it has changed both R
and python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities as mentioned earlier as
both R and python are open in nature all
the latest features are available
without any
delay moving on to the companies using R
we have Uber Google Facebook to name a
few python is used by many companies
again to name a few we have Amazon
Google and the American photo and video
sharing social networking service
Instagram that was all about RN
python at number four we have Apache
spark Apache spark is an open- Source
engine developed specifically for
handling large scale data processing and
analytics spark offers the ability to
access data in a variety of sources
including distributed file system htfs
openstack Swift Amazon S3 and
Cassandra it allows you to store and
process data in real time across various
clusters of computers using simple
programming
constructs Apache spark is designed to
accelerate analytics on Hadoop while
providing a complete Suite of
complimentary tools that include a fully
featured machine learning library a
graph processing engine and stream
processing so this is how the interface
of a pares spark looks
like now let's look at the important
features of aache
spark spark stores data in the ram hence
it can access the data quickly and
accelerate the speed of analytics spark
helps to run an application in a Hadoop
cluster up to 100 times faster in memory
and 10 times faster when running on
disk it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write write
applications in Java Scala r or python
Spar comes up with 80 high level
operators for interactive querying Spar
code for batch processing join stream
against historical data or run adhoc
queries on stream
State analytics can be performed better
as spark has a rich set of SQL queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics Etc Apache spark provides fall
tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data assets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero conviva Netflix iua loed Martin and
eBay are some of the companies that use
a part spark on a daily
basis at number three we have another
important growing data analysis tool
that is Click
view click view software is a product of
Click for business intelligence and data
visualization click view is a business
Discovery platform that provides
self-service bi for all business users
and
organizations with click view you can
analyze data and use your data
discoveries to support decision making
click viw is a leading business
intelligence and analytics platform in
Gartner magic
quadrant on the screen you can see how
the interface of Click view looks
like
now talking about its features click viw
provides interactive guided analytics
within memory storage technology during
the process of data Discovery and
interpretation of collected data The
Click view software helps the user by
suggesting possible
interpretations click view uses a new
patent in memory architecture for data
storage all the data from the different
sources is loaded in the ram of the
system and it is ready to be retrieved
from there it has the cap capability of
efficient social and mobile data
Discovery social data Discovery offers
to share individual Data Insights within
groups or out of it a user can add
annotations as an addition to someone
else's insights on a particular data
report click view supports mobile data
Discovery within an HTML F enabled touch
feature which lets the user search the
data and conduct data Discovery
interactively and explore other
server-based
applications click View performs olap
and ETL features to perform analytical
operations extract data from multiple
sources transform it for usage and load
it to a data
warehouse the companies that can help
you start your career in Click view are
Mercedes-Benz Cap Gemini City Bank
cognizant and Accenture to name a
few at number two we have
powerbi powerbi is a business analytic
solution that lets you visualize your
data and share insights across your
organization or embed them in your app
or
website it can connect to hundreds of
data sources and bring your data to life
with live dashboards and
reports powerbi is the collective name
for a combination of cloud-based apps
and services that help organizations
collate manage and analyze data from a
variety of sources through a
userfriendly
interface powerbi is built on the
foundation of Microsoft Excel and has
several components such as Windows
desktop application called powerbi
desktop and online software is a service
called powerbi service mobile powerbi
apps available on Windows phones and
tablets as well as for IOS and Android
devices here is how the powerbi
interface looks like as you can see
there is a visually interactive sales
report with different charts and graphs
moving on to the features of powerbi it
has an easy drag and drop functionality
with features that make data visually
appealing you can create reports without
having the knowledge of any programming
language powerbi helps users see not
only what's happened in the past and
what's happening in the present but also
what might happen in the
future it offers a wide range of
detailed and attractive visualization to
create reports and dashboards you can
select several charts and graphs from
the visualization pan powerbi has
machine learning capabilities with which
it can spot patterns in data and use
those patterns to make informed
predictions and run what of
scenarios powerbi supports multiple data
sources such as Excel Tech CSV Oracle
SQL Server PDF and XML files the
platform integrates with other popular
business management tools like like
SharePoint Office 365 and Dynamics 365
as well as other non-microsoft products
like spark Hadoop Google analytics sap
Salesforce and
MailChimp some of the companies using
powerbi are Adobe AXA carlsburg cap jini
and
Nestle moving on to the next tool so any
guesses as to what we have at number one
you can comment in the chat section
below
finally on the top of the pyramid we
have
tblo Gartner's magic quadrant of 2020
classified tblo as a leader in business
intelligence and data analysis tblo
interactive data visualization software
company was founded in Jan 2003 in
Mountain View
California tblo is a data visualization
software that is used for data science
and business intelligence it can create
a wide range of different visualization
to interactively present the data and
showcase
insights the important products of tblo
are tblo desktop tblo public tblo server
tblo online and tblo
reader this is how the interface of tblo
desktop looks
like now coming to the features of
tblo data analysis is very fast with
tblo and the visualizations created are
in the form of dashboards and worksheets
delivers interactive dashboards that
support insights on the
fly it can translate queries to
visualizations and import all ranges and
sizes of data writing simple SQL queries
can help join multiple data sets and
then build reports out of it you can
create transparent filters parameters
and
highlighters Tableau allows you to ask
questions spot Trends and identify
opportunities with the help of tblo
online you can connect with Cloud
databases Amazon redshift and Google big
query the companies using tblo are Deo
Adobe Cisco LinkedIn and the American
e-commerce giant Amazon to name a few
and there you go those are the top 10
data analysis tools since this is data
analysis with python we got to ask the
question why python for data analytics I
mean there's C++ there's Java there's
Donnet from Microsoft why do people go
to python for
it so the number of reasons one it's
easy to learn with simple
synext uh you don't have a very high
type set like you do in Java and other
coding so it allows you to kind of be a
little lazy in your programming uh that
doesn't mean that it can't be set that
way and that you don't have to be
careful it just makes means you can spin
up a code much quicker in Python the
same amount of code to do something in
Python A lot of times is one two or
three or four lines where when I did the
same thing say in Java I found myself
with 10 12 13 20 lines depending on what
it was it's very scalable and flexible
uh so there's our flexibility because
you can do a lot with it and you can
easily scale it up you can go from
something on your machine to using uh P
spark under the spark environment and
spread that across hundreds if not
thousands of servers across terabytes of
data or pedabytes of data so it's very
scalable there's a huge collection of
libraries this one's always interesting
because Java has a huge collection of
libraries C has a huge collection of
libraries Donnet does and they're always
in competition to get those libraries
out uh Scala for your spark all those
have huge collections of libraries this
is always changing uh but because
Python's open source you almost always
have easy to access libraries that
anybody can use you don't have to go
check your licensing and have special
licensing like you do in some
packages grab graphics and visualization
they have a really powerful package for
that so it makes it easy to create nice
displays for people to read and
community support because python is open
source it has a huge community that
supports it you can do a quick Google
and probably find a solution for almost
anything you're working
on python libraries let's bring it
together we have data analytics and we
have python so when we're talking data
analytics we're talking python libraries
for data analytics and the big five
player here is our numpy Panda's matplot
Library scipi which is going to be in
the background so we're not going to
talk too much about the scientific
formulas in CPI
andsit so numpy supports in dimensional
arrays provides numerical Computing
tools useful for linear algebra and for
year
transform um and you can think of this
is just a grid of numbers um and you can
even have uh a grid inside a grid or
data it's not even numbers because you
can also put uh words and characters and
just about anything into that array but
you can think of a grid and then you can
have a grid inside a grid and you end up
with a nice threedimensional array if
you want to talk threedimensional array
you can think of images you have your
three channels of color for if you have
an alpha and then you have your XY
coordinates for the image we're looking
at so you can go x y and then what are
the three channels to generate that
color and numpy isn't restricted to
three dimensions you could imagine uh
watching a movie well now you have your
movie clips and they each have their X
number of frames and each of those
frames have X number of XY coordinates
for the pictures in each frame and then
you have your three dimensions for the
colors so numpy is just a great way to
work with in dimensional
arrays now closely with numpy is pandas
uh useful for handling missing data
perform mathematical operations provides
functions to manipulate data pandas is
becoming huge because it is basically a
data frame and if you're working with
big data and you're working in spark or
any of the other major packages out
there you realize that the data frame is
very Central to a lot of that and you
can look at it as a Excel spreadsheet
you have your columns you have your rows
or indexes and uh you can do all kinds
of different manipulations of the data
within uh including filling in missling
data which is a big thing when you're
dealing with large pools or Lakes of
data where they might be collected
differently from different
locations and Matt plot Library we did
kick over the scipi which is a lot of
mathematical computations which usually
runs in the background of the F of numpy
and pandas um although you do use them
they're useful for a lot of other things
in there but the map plot Library that's
the final part that's what you want to
show people and this is your plotting
library in Python several toolkits
extend map plot Library functionality
there's like a hundred different
toolkits to extend matap plot Library
which range from uh how to properly
display star constellations from
astronomy there's a very specific one
built just for that all the way to some
uh very generic ones we'll actually add
Seaborn in when we do the labs in a
minute several toolkits extend met plot
Library functionality and it creates
interactive
visualization uh so there's all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as just
displaying graphs and there's even some
that you can create interactive graphs
we won't do the interactive Gras but
you'll see you'll get a a pretty good
grasp of some of the different things
you can do in matplot
library let's jump over to the demo
which is my favorite roll up our sleeves
get our hands in on what we're doing now
there's a lot of options when we're
dealing with python uh you can use py
charm is a really popular
one uh and you'll see this all over the
place um so it's one of the main ones
that's out there and there's a lot of
other ones I used to use net beans which
is has kind of lost favor uh don't even
have it installed on my new
computer but the most popular one right
now for data science now py charm's
really popular for python General
development for data science we usually
go to Jupiter uh notebook or anaconda
and we're going to jump into Anaconda
because that's my favorite one to go to
because it has a lot of external tools
for us we're not going to dig into those
but we will pop in there so you can see
what it looks like so with anacon we
have our Jupiter lab we have our
notebook these are identical Jupiter lab
is an upgrade to the notebook with
multiple tabs that's all it is and we'll
be using the notebook and you can see
that py charm is so popular with um
python that we even have it highlighted
here in Anaconda as part of the setup uh
Jupiter notebook can also be a
standalone uh so we're actually going to
be running Jupiter notebook and then you
have your different environments um I
have we're going to be under Main pi3 6
there's a root one and I usually label
it Pi
36 the reason is is currently as of
writing this tensor flow only works in
36 and not in 37 or 38 for doing neural
networks but you can actually have
multiple environments which is nice
they're they separate the kernel so it
helps protect your computer when you're
doing development and this is just a
great way to do a display or a demo
especially if you're looking for that
job pull up your laptop open it up or if
you're doing a meeting get it broadcast
up to the big screen so that the CEO can
see what you're looking
at and when we launch the notebook uh it
actually opens up a file browser in
whatever web browser you have this
happens to be Chrome and then you can
just go under new there's a lot of
different options depending what you
have installed uh Python 3 and this just
creates an Untitled uh version of this
and you can see here I'm actually in a
simply learn folder for other work I've
done for simply
learn uh and that's where I save all my
stuff and I can browse through other
folders making it really easy to jump
from one project to another and under
here we'll go ahead and change the name
of this and we'll go ahead and rename
it data analytics data analytics just so
I can remember what I was
doing which is probably about 50 of the
folders in here right or files in here
right
now uh so let's go ahead and jump in
there and take a look at some of these
different uh tools that we were looking
at and as we go through the demo let's
start with the uh numpy uh the least
visually exciting and I'm going to zoom
in here so you can see what we're
doing and the first thing we want to do
is import
numpy and we'll import it as NP that is
the most common numpy
terminology and let's go and change the
view so we also have the line numbers um
I don't know why we probably won't need
them but like it for easy reference uh
and then we'll create a onedimensional
array we just call this array one and it
equals np. array and you put your array
information in here in this case we'll
spell it out uh you can actually do like
a range and other ways there's lots of
ways to generate these arrays but we'll
just do one two three so three
integers and if we
print our array
one we can go ahead and run this and you
can see right here it prints one two 3
you can see why this is a really nice
interface to show other people you're
doing uh with the Jupiter notebook uh so
this is the basic we've created an array
this is a onedimensional array and then
the array is one two3 one of the nice
things about the Jupiter notebook is
whatever ran in this first setup is
still running it's still in the kernel
so it still has the nump imported as NP
and it still has our variable um arr1
for array one equal to NP array of 1 two
three so when we go to the next
cell we can check the type of the array
we're just going to print we say hey
what's what what what is this um setup
in here and we want
type um and then we want what is the
type of array one let's go ahead and run
that and it says class numpy indd array
so it's its own class that's all we're
doing is is checking to see what that
class
is and if you're going to look at the uh
array class uh probably the biggest
thing you do I don't know how many times
I find myself doing this uh because I
forget what I'm working on and I forget
I'm working with a three-dimensional or
four-dimensional array uh and I have to
reformat somehow so it works with
whatever other things I have and so we
do the array shape uh the array shape is
just three because it has three members
and it's a one-dimensional array that's
all that
is and with the numpy array we can
easily access um stick with the print
statement if you actually put a variable
in Jupiter notebook and it's a last one
in the cell it will the same as a print
statement so if I do this where array
one of two it's the same as doing
print array of two that's those are
identical statements in our Jupiter
notebook we'll go and stick with the
print on this one and it's three so
there's our print space two and we have
0 1 2 2 = 3 we can easily change that so
we have array one of place two
equals
5 and then if we print our array
one uh you can see right down here when
it comes out it's one two and five and
there I leftt the print statement off
because it's the last variable in the
list um it'll always print the variable
if you just put it in like that that's a
Jupiter notebook thing don't do that in
P charm I've forgotten before doing a
demo and we talked about multiple
Dimensions so we'll do an array um
two-dimensional array okay and this is
again a numpy
array and in the numpy array we need um
our first Dimension we'll do one two 3
and
our second dimension uh 3 four five and
you can see right here that when we hit
the uh we'll do this we'll just do array
two and we can run that and there's our
array two 1 2 3 3 4 5 we can also do
array
two of uh
one and then we can do let's do zero
doesn't really matter which one actually
let's do uh two there we go and if I run
this it'll print out five uh because
here we are this is zero uh 0 1 2 3 is
on our zero row 345 is on our one row we
start with zero and then the two 0 one
two goes to the
five
and then maybe we forgot what we are
working with so we'll go do array 2.
shape and if we do array two of
shape uh we'll go and run that we'll see
we have two rows and each row has three
elements a two-dimensional array two
three if you looked up here when we did
it before it just had three comma
nothing when you have a single entity it
always saves it as a tupal with a blank
space uh but you can see right here we
have 2 comma
3 and if you remember from up here we
just did this array two of oh let's go
what is it one comma
2 we run that we get the five you can
also count backwards this is kind of fun
and you'll see I just kind of Switched
something on you because you can also do
one comma two to get to the same spot um
now two is the last one 0 one2 it's the
last one in there we can count backwards
and do minus one and if we run this we
get the same answer whether we count it
as uh let's go back up here whether we
count this as 0 one 2 or we count
backwards as minus1 min-2 minus 3 and
you can see that if I change this minus
one to a minus two and run
that I get four which is going backwards
minus one min-2 so there's a lot of
different ways to reference what we're
working on inside the numpy array it's
really a cool tool it's got a lot of
things you can do with
it and we talked about the fact that it
can also hold things that are not values
and we'll call this array ask for
Strings equals uh np.
array put our setup in there brackets
and let's
go
China
um
[Music]
India
USA uh
Mexico matter we can make whatever we
want on here and if we print that
out we run this you can see that we get
our numpy array China India USA Mexico
it even gives us our dtype of a
U6 and a lot of times when you're
messing with data we'll call this array
R for range just to kind of keep it
uniform np. a range so this is a command
inside numpy to create a range of
numbers and if you're testing data Maybe
you want maybe you have equal time
increments um that are spaced a certain
point apart but in this case we're just
going to do
integers and we're going to do a uh a
setup from 0 20 skipping every other one
and we'll print it out and see what that
looks
like and you can see here we have 0 2 4
6 8 10 12 14 16 18 like you expected it
skips every one
and just a quick
note there's no 20 on here uh why well
this starts at zero and counts up to 20
so if you're used to another language
where explicitly says uh less than or
less than equal to 20 like for xal 0 um
x++ uh X is less than 20 that's what
this is it just assumes X is less than
20 on
here and if we want to create a very
uniform uh set you know 0 2 4 6 what
happens if I want to create numbers uh
from 0 to 10 but I need 20 increments in
there uh we can do that with line space
so we can create um an R uh we'll call
this
L equals I don't think we'll actually
use any of this again so I don't know
why I'm creating unique um identifiers
for it uh but we'll do
NP uh Lin
space
and we're going to do
0o to 10 or 0 to 9 uh remember it
doesn't it goes up to 10 and then we
want to let's say we have
20 different um increments in there so
we're creating a we have a data set and
we know it's over a certain time period
and we need to divide that time period
by 20 and it happens to just have 10
pieces in it um and here we go you can
see right here we have TW or it has 20
pieces in it but it's over 10 years we
got to divide it in the middle and you
can see it does it goes 0.52 remember
yeah there's our 10 on the end so it
goes up to
10 uh and then we can also do random
there's np. random if you're doing
neural
networks uh usually you start it by
seating it with random
numbers and we'll just do np. random and
we'll just call this array we'll stop
giving it unique numbers we'll print
that one out and run it and you can see
we have random numbers they are 0er to
one so you'll see that all these numbers
are under one and you can easily alter
that by multiplying them out or
something like that if you want to do
like 0 to 100 um you can also round them
up if it's integer 0 to 100 there's all
kinds of things you can do but generates
a random float between zero and one and
you have a couple options you could
reshape that um or you can just generate
them uh in whatever shape you want and
so we can see here uh we did three and
four and so you can see three rows by
four
variables same thing as doing a reshape
of 12 variables to three and
four and if you're going to do that you
might need an empty data set um I have
had this come up many times or I need to
start off with zero and I don't know you
know because I'm going to be adding
stuff in there or it might be zero and
one or one is uh if you're removing the
background of an image you might want
the background is zero and then you
figure out what the images and you set
all those boxes to one and you create a
mask so creating mask over images is
really big and doing that with uh a
numpy array of
zero and we can also
uh give it a
space and we'll just do this all in one
shot this time and we'll do the same
thing like we did
before zeros and in this case we'll do
uh 2 comma 3 and so when we run this
forgot the asteris around it I knew I
was forgetting something there we go so
when we run this uh you can see here we
have our 10 zeros in a row and maybe
this is a mask for an image and so it
has uh two rows of three digits in it so
it's a very small image um little tiny
pixel and maybe you're looking to do
something the opposite way uh instead of
uh creating a mask of zero and filling
in with ones uh maybe you want to create
a mask of ones and fill them in with
zeros and we'll just do just like we did
before we'll do three comma four and
when we run this you'll see it's all
ones and we could even do this even uh
we'll do it this way let's do
10 10 x 10 icon and then you have your
three colors you so creates quite a
large array there for doing pictures and
stuff like that when you add that third
dimension
in um if we take that off it's a little
bit easier to
see U we'll do 10
again and you can easily see how we have
10 rows of 10
ones and you can also do something uh
like create an
array and we'll do 0 one
2 and then in this array um we actually
print it right out we want want a repeat
so you can actually do a repeat of the
array and maybe you need this array um
let's repeat it three
times so there's our repeat of an array
repeat three
times and if we run this you'll see we
have 00111
222 and whenever I think of a repeat I
don't really think of repeating being
the first digit three times the second
digit I really always think of it as um
012 012 012 it catches me every time uh
but the actual code for that one is
going to be tile uh and again if we do
arrange
three and we run this you can see how
you can generate 012 012
012 and if you're dealing with um an
identity Matrix um we can do that also
if you're big on you're doing your
matrixes and we'll just uh
identity I guess we'll go and spill it
out today
Matrix and the command we're looking for
is um I eye and we'll do three and then
we'll just go ahead and print this
out there we go there's our identity
Matrix and it comes out by a 3X3 array
because there's our
Matrix uh and then it puts the ones down
the middle
and for doing your different Matrix math
and we can manipulate that a little bit
too um we talk
about uh
matrixes we might not want ones across
the middle in which case we now have uh
the diagonal so we can do an np.
diagonal and we do a diagonal uh let's
put in the
diagonal one two three four five and
when we run this
again this generates a value and by just
putting that value in there is the same
as putting print around it or putting
array equals and then print array and
you can see it generates a diagonal 1 2
3 4 5 and there's your uh your beginning
of your Matrix array for working with
matrixes and we can actually go in
reverse uh let's create an array equals
remember our
random random. random and we'll do a 5x5
array uh oops there we go
5 by
five and just so you can see what that
looks
like helps if I T don't mistype the
numbers which is in this case I just
need to take out the brackets and there
you go you have your your 5x5 array set
up in there and we can know because
we're working with matrixes we might
want to do this in reverse and extract
the diagonals which would be the 79 the
678 and so
on and we simply type in np.
diagonal we put our array in there um
and this will of course print it out
because it returns it as a variable and
you can see here here's our diagonal
going across from our
Matrix and we did talk about shape
earlier if you remember you can do um
print the shape out you can also do the
dimensions uh so in Dimensions very
similar to shape it comes out and just
has two Dimensions we can also look at
the size so if we do a size on here we
can run that and you can see has a size
of 25 two dimensions and of course 5x5
and that was from the shape from earlier
that we looked at uh there's our 5x5
shape and if you remember earlier we did
random well you can also do uh random I
talked a little bit about manipulating
zero to one and how you can get
different answers you can also do
straight for the integer part and we'll
do minus uh 10 to 10
4 and so we're going to Generate random
integers between minus 10 to 10 uh we're
going to generate four of those and so
when we run that we have 7 - 3 - 6 - 3
they're all be between - 10 and 10 and
there's four of
them and now we jump into some of the
functionality of arrays uh which is
really great because this is where they
come
in here's the array and you can add tin
to it and if I run this um there takes
my original array from up
here with the integers and adds 10 to
all of those values so now we have oh
this is the decimal that's right this is
a random decimal I had stored in
Array um but this takes a random decim
the random numbers I had from zero to
one and adds 10 to them and we can just
as easily do uh minus
10 uh we could even
do times
two
and we could do divide by
two and it would it'll take that random
number we generated and cut it in half
so now all these numbers are under 0.
five uh another way you can change the
numbers to what you need on
there and as you dig deeper into numpy
we can also do exponential so as an
exponential function uh which should
generate some interesting numbers off of
the random so we're taking them to the
power I don't even remember what the
original numbers in the um array were
because we did the random numbers up
there here's our original numbers and if
you build an exponential on there uh
this is where you get e to the X on this
and just like you can do e to the X you
can also do the log so if you're doing
logarithmic
functions that reinforc learning you
might be doing some kind of log setup on
there and you can see the logarithmic of
these different array
numbers and if you're working with uh
log base
2 you can do you can just change it in
there NP log 2 you have to look it up
because this is not log 1 2 3 4 5 um it
is Log and log two uh so just a quick
note that's not a variable going in that
is an actual command there's a number of
them in there and you'll have to go look
and see uh what the documentation is but
you can also do log 10 so here's log
value
10 uh some other really cool functions
you can do with this is your sign so we
can take a sign value of all of our
different uh values in there and if you
have sign you of course have
cosine we can run that uh so here's the
cosine of those and if you're doing
activations in your numpy array and
you're doing a tangent activation uh
there's your tangent for
that and the tangent activation is
actually uh from uh neural networks
that's one of the ways you can activate
it because it forms a nice nice curve
between uh from whether you're
generating one to negative one uh with
some discrepancy in the
middle just jumping a little bit in
there into neural
networks and then we get into let me
just put the array back out there so
that we can see it uh while we're doing
this as we're getting into this you can
also sum the values so we have NP
sum and you can do a summation of all
the values in this array and you'll see
that if you added all these together
they'd equal
12519 so on I don't know what the whole
setup is in
there uh but you can see right here the
the summation of this one of the things
you can also do is by axes so we could
do axes equals zero and if we run the
summation of the axis equal
zero and you can think of that uh in
numpy as the rows so that would be uh or
you can think of that in numpy as being
the columns we're summing these columns
going across and you can also change
this to
one and now we're summing the
rows and so that is the summation of
this row and so forth and so forth going
down and maybe you don't need to um know
the summation maybe what you're looking
for is the
minimum uh so here's our minimal you're
looking for and this comes up a a lot
because you have like your errors we
want to find the minimal error inside of
this array and just like um the other
one we can do a is equal
Z and you can see here
0645 is the smallest number in this
First Column is 0645 and so
on and if you have a minimum well you
might also want to know the max maybe
we're looking for the maximum profit and
here we go you can see maximum 79 is a
maximum on this first column and just
like we did before you can change this
to a one on axes you can take the axes
out of here and just find the max value
for the whole array and the max value in
here was 08344 so on so
on and since we're talking data
analytics uh we want to go ahead and
look at the mean uh pretty much the same
as the average this is the mean across
the whole thing and just like we did
before we could also do axis equals zero
and then you'll see this is the mean of
this axis and so on and we have mean we
might want to know the
median and there's our median our most
common numbers uh if we have median we
might want to know the standard
deviation or if we have the average a
lot of times you do the means in the
standard deviation um we can run that
and there's our standard deviations
along the axes we can also do it across
the whole
array
uh if we're going to do standard
deviations there's also uh
variance which is your
V and there's our variance across the
different
levels and so if we looked at that we
looked at variance we looked at standard
deviation the median and the means
there's more but those are the most
common ones used with data analytics um
and I'm going through your data and
figuring out uh uh what you're going to
present to the
shareholders and some other things we
can do is we can actually take slices uh
you'll hear that
terminology and a slice might be um like
we have a 5x5 array but maybe we don't
want the whole array maybe we want uh
from one on we don't want the zero in
there so we got up to four and maybe on
the second part we just
want two to row three and see this
notation right here says one to the end
and if we run this you can see how that
generates
a single row to the end and then row two
and three now remember it doesn't
include three that's why we only get the
one column so if you wanted two and
three you would need to go ahead and go
two to four so goes up to four we could
also do this in Reverse just like we
learned earlier we can go minus one
oops and when we go to minus one it's
the same thing because we have 0 1 2 3 4
this is the same thing as 2 to four goes
two to the last
one also very common with arrays is
you're going to want to sort them so we
still have our array up here that we
randomly generated and we might want to
um sort it and we'll go and throw an
axis back in there uh axis equals one if
we run this you can see from the axes
that it sorts it uh the point 2 being
the lowest value to the highest value by
the row we can also change this of
course to axis zero if you're sorting it
by column so maybe your values are based
on columns and then of course you can do
the whole
array and we can sort that don't usually
do that but you know I guess sometimes
you might that might come
up and so you can see right here we have
a nice sorted array uh something now
let's just go ahead and reprint our
array so we can look at it again
starting to get too many boxes up there
uh something else you can do with an
array is we can take and transpose it
this comes up more than you would think
when you transpose it you'll see that um
the rows and the column are transposed
so where 79.
57064 is the column now we've switched
it and we have 7 9.42 as the
index you can see this really more
dramatic if we take a
slice and we'll just do a slice of the
first couple and then we'll just do all
the other um the full rows and if we run
this you can see how it comes up a
little bit different and we'll just do
the same slice up here so you can see
how those two look next to each
other there we go there's our slice run
uh and so you can see the slice comes up
and it has H one two three four five
columns now we have 1 2 3 four five rows
and three columns versus three rows
and the original version when they first
started putting this um together uh was
a function so the original version was
transpose and this still works you can
still see it generates the same value as
just a capital T so many times we flip
this data because we'll have an XY value
or we'll have an image or something like
that and it's being read one way into
the next process and the next one needs
it the opposite uh so this actually
happens a lot you need to know how to
transpose the data really
quick and we can go ahead oh let's just
take um here's our transpose we'll just
stick with the transpose on here and
instead of uh doing it this way we might
need to do something called flattening
why would you flatten your data uh if
this is an array going into a neural
network you might want to send it in as
one set of values instead of two rows
and you can see here is all the values
as a single array it just flattens it
down into one array
so we covered our scientific uh means
transpose median um some different
variations on here some of the other
things we want to do is what happens if
we want to pin to our array uh so let's
create a new array getting tired of
looking at the same set of random
numbers we generated earlier um so we'll
go and create a new array here something
a little simpler so it's easier to see
what we're
doing and four five 6 7 eight uh that's
good enough we just do four five six S
8 and if we print this
array there it is 4 5 6
78 and we might want to pend something
to the array so we have our array we
need to extend it you got to be very
careful about appending things to your
array and there's a number of reasons
for that uh one is runtime because of
the way the numpy array is set up a lot
of s you build your data and then push
it into the numpy array instead of
continually adding on to the array um
and then it also usually it
automatically generates a copy for
protecting your data so there's a lot of
reasons to be careful about a pending
this way uh but you can certainly do it
and we can just take our array we're
going to create a new array array one
and if we print array one and we append
8 to it you'll see four five six s and
then there's our a to pended on to the
end
and if you want to appin something to an
array um you'd probably also want to
whoops array one let's try that again
there we go now we have the eight
appended on to the end um so you can see
four five six seven eight and then we
pinned another eight on
there and if you're going to appin
something you might want to um go ahead
and insert instead of appending it might
be you need to keep a certain order and
we can do the same thing we do our array
um and we're going to pin or um insert
at the beginning and let's go ahead and
insert uh one 2 three one two 3 and we
go ahead and print our array to we run
it and you can see one two three is
inserted at the beginning uh inserts a
lot more powerful and that you can put
it anywhere in the array we can move it
to the one spot and there we go one two
three uh we can do a minus one just for
fun and you'll see it comes up uh 1 two
3 we're counting backwards by one I
imagine you can do minus
0 and run this and it turns out that
minus 0 puts it back at the beginning
because that's why registers a zero just
takes a minus sign
off and just like we add numbers on we
might want to delete numbers and so uh
let's do an np. delete well let's let's
keep it a little bit make it a little
easy here um to watch we'll go and
create an array three and we'll do NP
delete we were just working with array
uh
two and what we want to do is delete
zero space uh so if you look at this
here's our array two array two starts
with one and when we delete the space on
here and print that out uh we deleted
the one right out of
there and we can also do something like
this where we can do it as a slice and
we can do let's do one comma 3 and if we
run one comma 3 you'll see we've deleted
the one space and the three space out
which deleted our two and
four now keep in mind when you're
messing with um adding lines and
deleting
lines uh you have to be really careful
because there's a time element involved
um as far as where the data is coming
from and it's really easy to delete the
wrong data and corrupt what you're
working on or to insert stuff where you
don't want it um so there always a
warning we talk about manipulating numpy
arrays and just like anything else we're
doing uh we'll create an array C which
equals we'll just do our um our numpy
array that we just created our numpy
array three and we can do copy so you
can make a copy of it U maybe you want
to protect your original data or maybe
you're making a mask and so you copy the
array and then the new array make all
these alterations and change it from
values to 0 to one to mask over were the
first one and of course we if we do um
array C since it equals a copy of uh
array three it's the same thing 1 3 5 6
8 and now we're getting into uh combine
and split arrays I end up doing a lot of
this and I don't know how many times I
end up fiddling with this and having a
mess uh so but but you do it a lot you
know you combine your arrays you split
them you might need one set of data for
one thing another set of data for the
other
so let's go a and create two arrays
array one array two and I want you to
note and the terminology we're going to
look for is concatenate what that means
is we're going to take um we'll call
this a ray cat I like array cat there we
go um our array cat or concatenated
array we're taking array one and two and
it's very important to really pay
attention to to your axes and your
counts I can't merge two arrays that
have like if their axes are messed up
and I'm merging on axis zero it's going
to give me an error and I'll have to
reshape them so you got to make sure
that whatever you're concatenating
together works and what that
means as you can see here we have 1 2 3
4 1 2 3 4 and then 5 6 7 8 5678 along
the zero axis these each are four values
um so it's a 2x4 value and if we go
ahead and switch this to one you can see
how that's that flips it a little bit so
now we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 it's
interesting that we chose that one if I
did something like
this where this is
now there we go and we can catenate it
um run this and it gives me an answer
okay because I have two by two and I'm
using axis one but if I switch this to
axis zero where now it's got three and
five
it gives me an error so you got to be
really careful on that to make sure that
your whatever axes you are putting
together that they match um so like I
said this one oops axis one axis one has
two entities and since we're going on
axis one or by row you can see that it
lets it merge it right onto the end
there and you could imagine this if this
was a XY plot of value or the x value
going in and the predicted yvalue coming
out and then you have another predict
and you want to combine them this works
really easy for that and we'll go back
and let's just put this back to where we
had
it oops I forgot how many changes I made
there we go 'll just put it Oops I
messed up on my concatenation order
[Music]
here there we
go okay so you can see that we went
through the different concatenation Act
is really important when you're doing
your concatenation values on here and
we'll switch this back to one just
because I like the looks of that better
there we go two
rows now there are other commands in
here um so we can do uh cap V equals
npv v stack this is nothing more than
your
concatenation uh but instead we don't
have to put the axes in there uh cuz
it's V stands for vertical and so if we
print out
cat V and we run this you can see we get
the 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and that would be
the same as making this axis zero for
vertical stack and if you're going to
have a vertical stack uh you can also
have an H
stack so if we change this to from v
stack to oops here we go H stack and
we'll just change this from cat to cat
and I run
this it's the same as doing axis zero
the process is identical in the
background um this is like a legacy
setup uh your vstack and your hstack
most people just use concatenate and
then put the axes in there because it's
much uh has a lot more clarity and um is
more more commonly used
nowadays the last section in numpy we're
going to cover uh
is is kind of uh data exploration um and
that'll make a little bit more sense in
just a moment sometimes they call them
set operations but let's say we have an
array 1 2 3 4 5 6 three whatever it is
uh you we generate ni little array here
and what I want to go ahead and do is
find the unique values in that
array uh so maybe I'm generating what
they call a one hot incoder and so these
values then all become I need to know
how long my bit array is going to be be
so each word how many how many each word
is represented by a number and then I
want to know just how many of those
words are in there if we're doing word
count very popular thing to
do um and you can see here when we do
unique uh we have 1 2 3 four five six
those are our unique
values uh some of the things we can do
with the unique values is we can also
instead of doing just unique we can do
uniques or unique values and counts of
each unique value and this is very
similar to what we just did up here
where we uh we're doing NP unique uh but
we're going to add a little bit more
into there and it's just part of the
arguments in this and we want to do
return counts equals true so in instead
of just returning the unique values uh
we want to know how many of those unique
values are in each one and we'll go
ahead and
print our
uniques and print
our
counts when we run that uh you can see
here we have our unique value 1 2 3 four
5 six just like we had before and then
there's two of the first of two ones two
twos two 3es two fours one five two
sixes and so on and you can go through
and actually look at that if you want to
count them um but a quick way to find
out your um distribution of different
values so you might want to know how
often the word the' is used versus the
word and if each word word is
represented as a unique
number and along the set variables we
might want to know um let me just put a
note up here we're going to start
looking
at uh
intersection and we might want to also
know
differentiation and uh
neither so when we're whoops
neighbor neither
um so what we're looking at now is we
want to know hey where do these two
arrays intersect and we have 1 2 3 4 5 3
4 5 6 7 we might want to know what is
common between the two
arrays um and so when we do that we have
um
NP
intersect and it's a ond array
onedimensional
array and then we need to go ahead and
put array uh one array two
and if we run
this we can see they intersect at 3 4
five that's what they have
common uh and because we're going to go
ahead and go through these and look at a
couple different options let's change
this from intersect
1D and we'll do the same thing we'll go
a and print this so we might want to
know the intersection uh where they have
commonalities another uh unique word is
Union of 1D uh so instead of uh
intersect we want to know all the values
that are in both of them so here's our
Union of 1D when we run that you can see
we have one 2 3 4 5 6 7 so it's all the
different values in
there and the last one of the last words
we have two more to go uh is we want to
know what the set difference
is uh and so that's where the you'll see
if you remember set we talked about that
being the what they call these things um
so the set
difference of a one D array when we run
that you can see that one is only in one
array and two is only in one
array and if we want to know uh what's
in Array one but not in Array two we
might want to know what is in Array one
but not two and what's in two but not
one uh and this would be the set X or 1D
on here uh so we have the four different
options here where we can do an
intersection what do they both have in
common uh we can do a Union what are all
the unique values in both arrays we can
see the difference what's in Array one
but not array two so set diff 1D and
then set X or what is not in one but is
in two and what is not in two but in
one so we dug a lot in numpy because
we're talking um there's a lot of
different little mathematical things
going on in numpy a lot of this can also
be done in pandas although usually the
heavy lifting is for numpy because
that's what it's designed for let's go
ahead and open up another Python
3 setup in here and so we want to
explore uh what happens when you want to
display this this is where it starts
getting in my opinion a little fun
because you're actually playing with it
and you have something to show people
and we'll go ahead and rename this we're
going to call this uh
pandas uh and pip plot so Panda's pip
plot just so we can remember for next
time and we want to go ahead and import
the necessary libraries we're going to
import pandas as PD now remember this is
a data frame so we're talking rows and
columns and you'll see how uh pandas
work so nicely uh when you're actually
showing data to people and then we're
going to have numpy in the background
numpy works with pandas uh so a lot of
times you just import them by
default Seaborn sits on top of the map
plot Library uh so sometimes we use the
caborn because it kind of extends it's
one of the 100 packages that extends the
map plot Library probably the most
common used because it has a lot of
built-in functionality um almost by
default I usually just put caborn in
there in case I need it and of course we
have matplot Library as pyplot as
PLT and note we have as PD as NP as SNS
as PLT those are pretty standard so when
you're doing your Imports I would
probably keep those just so other people
can read your code and it makes sense to
them that's pretty much a standard
nowadays and then we have the strange
line here uh it says uh amber sign
matplot Library
inline that is for Jupiter notebook only
so if you're running this in a different
package you'll have a popup when it goes
to display the matplot library um you
can with the most current version of
Jupiter usually leave that out and it
will still display it right on the page
as we go and we'll see what that looks
like and then we're going to go ahead
and just uh do the um caborn the SNS do
set and we're going to set the color
codes equals true
let them uh just keep the default one so
we don't have to think about it too
much and we of course have to run this
um the reason we run this is because
these values are all set if we don't run
this and I access one of these um
afterward it'll it'll crash the cool
thing about Jupiter uh notebooks is if
you forgot to import one of these you
forgot to install it because you do have
to install this under your anaconda
setup or whatever setup you're in you
can flip over to Anaconda and run your
install for these um and then just come
back and run it you don't have to close
anything
out and we'll go ahead and paste this
one in here real quick where we have car
equals pd. read CSV and then we have uh
the actual path this path of course will
vary depending on what you are working
with uh so it's wherever you saved the
file at and you can see here I have um
like my one drive documents simply Learn
Python data analytics using python slash
car CSV it's quite a long
file when we open that up what we get is
we get a CSV file and we have the make
the model the year the engine fuel type
uh engine horsepower cylinders and so on
um and this is just a comma separated
file so each row is like a row of data
think of it as a um
spreadsheet and then each one is a
column of data on here and as you can
see right here it has the uh make model
so it has columns for a header on
here now your pandas just does an
excellent job of automatically pulling a
lot of this in so when you start seeing
the pandas on here you realize that you
are already like halfway done with
getting your data in uh I just love
pandas for that reason numpy also has it
you can load a CSV directly into numpy
um but we're working with pandas and
this is where it really gets cool is I
can come down here and I can print uh
you remember our print statement we can
actually get rid of it and we're just
going to do car head cuz it's going to
print that out the head is going to
print the top values of that data file
we just ran in and so you can see right
here it does a nice print out it's all
nice and inline because we're in jupyter
Notebook I can scroll back and forth and
look at the different data uh and just
like we expected we have our column it
brought the header right in one thing to
note is the index IND it automatically
created an index 0 1 2 3 4 and so on and
we're just looking at the head so we got
0 1 2 3
4 um you can change this you might want
to just look at the top two we can run
that there's our top two
BMWs um another thing we can do is
instead of head we can do
tail and look at the last three values
that are in that data file and uh you
can see right here it numbered them all
the way up to 11
9113 oh my goodness they put a lot of
data in this file I didn't even look to
see how big the file was uh so you can
really easily get through and view the
different data in here when you're
talking about Big
Data you almost never just print out car
uh in fact let's see what happens when
we do if we run this and we just run the
car it's huge uh in fact it's so big
that the pandas automatically truncates
it and just does head plus tail so you
can see see the two um so we really
don't want to look at the whole thing
we'll go and go back to we'll stick with
the head displaying our data there we go
so there's ahead of our data it gives us
a quick look to see what's actually in
there um I can zoom out if we want so
you can actually get a better
view although we'll keep it zoomed in so
you can see the code I'm working
on and then from the data standpoint we
course want to look at um data types uh
what's going on with our data what does
it look like uh now this you know you
show your when you're talking to your
shareholders they like to see these nice
easy to read charts they look like a
spreadsheet uh so it's a nice way of
displaying pieces of the
chart when we talk about the data types
now we're getting into the data science
side of it what are we working with well
we have a make model we have an integer
64 for the year uh engine fuel type is
an object if we go up here you can see
that there
most of them are um like you know it's a
set manual rear wheel drive uh so they
might be very limited number of types in
there uh and so forth and you it's
either going to be a float 64 an integer
or an object is the way it's going to
read it on
here and the next thing you going to
know is like your
columns and since it loaded the columns
automatically uh we have here the make
the model the year the engine
the size all the way up to the
MSRP and um just out of something you'll
see come up a lot is whenever you're in
pandas you type in values it converts it
from a panda's uh list to a numpy
array and that's true of any of these uh
so then you end up in a numpy array so
you'll see a little switch in there in
the way that the data is actually stored
and that's true of any of these uh in
this case so we want car.
columns you have a total list of your
car columns and like any good data um
scientist we want to start looking at
analytical summary of the data set
what's going on with our data so we can
start trying to um piece Mill it
together so we can do
car uh
describe and then we'll do is we'll do
include equals all uh so a nice Panda
command is to describe your data and if
you're working with r this should start
looking familiar uh and we come down
here and you can see um count there's a
make the model the year um how many of
each one how many unique values of each
one uh the top value of each one what's
most common the frequency the mean um
clearly on some of these it's an object
so it really can't tell you what the um
average is you it' just be the top ones
the average I guess um the year what's
the average year on there um all this
stuff comes down here your standard
deviation your minimum value your
maximum value uh what's in the lower
quarter 50% Mark where's that line at
and what's in the upper 75% the top 25%
going into the
max now this next part is just cool uh
this is what we always wanted computers
to be back like in the '90s instead of
5,000 lines of code to do this maybe not
5,000 all right I built my own plot uh
Library back in 95 and the amount of
code for doing a simple plot was um I
don't know probably about 100 lines of
code this is being done in one line of
code we have our car which is our pandas
we generated that it's our data frame
and we have his for histogram that is
the power of Seaborn now it's still
going to generate a numpy graph but
caborn sits on top and then we can do
the figure size this is just um so it
fits nicely on the paper on here and we
do something simple like this and you
can see here where it comes up and it
does say Matt plot library and does
subplots and
everything but we're looking at a
histogram of all the different pieces in
our database and we have our engine
cylinders um that's always a good one
because you can see like they have some
that are they had a null on there so
they came out of zero um maybe a couple
maybe one of them had a two-cylinder
engine way back when four is a common uh
six a little less common and then you
see the 8 cylinder uh 12 cylinder
engines Bo that's got to be a Speedster
or something uh but you can see right
here it just breaks it down so now you
have uh how many cars with how many
whatever it is cylinders horsepower uh
and so on and it does a nice job
displaying it you can see if you're
working with your uh um you're going
into your uh demo it's really nice just
to be able to type that in and boom
there it is I can see it all the way way
across and we might want to zero in uh
and use like a box plot and this time
we'll go ahead and call the um Seaborn
SNS box plot and we're going to go ahead
and do um vehicle size in versus um
engine horsepower XY plot and the data
comes from the car so if we run this we
end up with a nice box plot you see our
midsize Compact and large you can see
the variation there's our outlier
showing up there on the compact that
must be a high-end sports car uh large
car might have a couple engines and
again we have all these outliers and
then your deviation on
them very powerful and quick way to zero
in on one small piece of data and
display it for people who need to have
it reduced to something they can see and
look at and understand and that's our
Seaborn box plot or SNS dobox
plot and then if we're going to back out
and we want a quick look at um what they
call pair plotting we can run that and
you can see with the caborn it just does
all the work for you it takes it just a
moment for it to pull the data in and
compile
it and once it does it creates a nice
grid um in this grid if you look at uh
this one space here which is you might
not be able to see the small number says
engine horsepower this is engine
horsepower uh to the year was built and
it's just flipped so everything to the
right of the middle diagonal is just the
rotation of what's on the left and as
you expect um the engine horsepower um
gets bigger and bigger and bigger as
time goes on so the the year it was
built further up in the year the more
likely you are to have a heavy
horsepower
engine and you can quickly look at
Trends with our pair plot coming up uh
and look how fast that was that was it
took it a you know moment to process uh
but right away I get a nice view of all
these different um information which I
can look at visually and and kind of see
how things group and
look now if I was doing a meeting I
probably wouldn't show all the data
um one of the things I've learned over
the years is um people myself included
love to show all our work you know we
were taught in school show all your work
prove what you know the CEO doesn't want
to see a huge U grid of of graphs I
guarantee it uh so we want to do is we
want to go ahead and
drop um the stuff that might not be
interested in and we're going to I'm not
really a car person guing the back is
obviously so you have your engine fuel
type we're going to drop that we're
going to drop Market category vehicle
style popularity number of doors vehicle
size um and we have the axes in here if
you remember from numpy we have to
include that axis to make it clear what
we're working on that's also true with
pandas and then we'll look at just what
what it looks like um from the the head
and you can see that we dropped out
those categories and now we have the
make model year uh and so forth um and
we took out the engine fuel type Market
category
Etc uh and this should look familiar to
you now when you start working with
pandas I just love pandas for this
reason look how easy it is it just
displays it as a nice um spreadsheet for
you you can just look at it and view it
very easily uh it's also the same kind
of view you're going to get if you're
working in spark or P Spark
which is python for spark across Big
Data this is the kind of thing that they
they come up with this is why pandas is
so
powerful and we might look at this and
decide we don't like these columns and
so you can go in here and we can
actually rename the
columns simple command car equals car
rename uh columns equals engine
horsepower equals
horsepower this is just your standard
python
dictionary um so it just Maps them out
and you know instead of having like a
lengthy here we had um engine horsepower
we just want horsepower we don't need to
know it's the engine horsepower engine
cylinders we don't need to know that
it's for the engine because there's only
one thing we're describing if we're
talking about cars and that's
cylinders uh we go ahead and just run
this and again here's our car head and
you can see how that changed we have
model year and horsepower versus model
year engine horsepower engine cylinders
just
cylinders again we want to keep red
reducing this so it's more and more
readable the more readable you get it
the better um and of course we can also
adjust the size a little bit so that
when it prints out instead of splitting
it on two lines we get like a single
line we can do that also that's just
your control mouse up or plus sign you
use in Chrome that's a chrome
command and if you remember from numpy
we had shape well pandas works the same
way uh we can look at the shape of the
data so we now have um
11,914 rows and 10 columns uh so you see
some similarities CU pandas is built on
numpy and questions that come up just
like you did in numpy we might want to
know duplicate rows and so we can do car
and look at this switch here um we're
doing a selection this is a panda
selection with the brackets but we want
to select it based on car. duplicated so
how many duplicates on
there so it's starting to look a little
bit different as far as how we access
some of the data on here this can be a
logical statement and we get the number
of duplicate rows we have 989 rows by 10
columns
again and this is one of those
troubleshooting things that we end up
doing uh a lot more than we really feel
like we should uh we might go ahead and
do like a car count uh just to see how
many rows we're dealing with and then
right after that we might want to go
ahead and say hey um let's drop
duplicates so remember we did all the
duplicates on there so car equals car.
drop duplicates and then we can print
the head again we'll just do car head
here and you can see the data on there
um looks the same as
before uh and just note that we did car
equals car draw
duplicates there are commands in here
where you can do where it changes the
actual value and it works on some of
them and not on others depending on what
you're doing but by default it always
returns a c copy so when we do this
we're reassigning it to car and you can
see it's the same header but we want to
go ahead and do count and see how the
count changes let's go ahead and run
this and you can see here instead of
11914 we have
10,925 uh so we've removed about a 100
cars that were duplicated just slightly
under a 100
there and then as we're prepping our
data we might want to know um car is
null uh so it's going to count the
values of null and then we want to sum
that up and when we do that uh we do the
car is null function. suum uh we end up
with uh HP the horsepower is 69 have
null values and 30 have cylinders have
null values now if you don't put the sum
at the end it's just going to return a
mask with the true false of is it null
or is it not by zero and one so you're
summing up the ones underneath each
column
and this of course then you have to
decide what you're going to do with the
uh null values there's a lot of
different options it might be that you
need to put in the average or means uh
maybe you want to put in the median
value um there's a lot of different ways
to fill it usually when you first start
out with the data a lot of them you just
drop your null values and you can see
here car. drop na which is equal to all
and then we're going to go ahead and
count it and you can see that we've
dropped almost another 100 values so
from
10925 to
10827 maybe 75 or so values uh so we
clean the this is really a big part of
cleaning data you need to know how to
get rid of your null values or at least
count them and what to do with them and
of course if we go back to um uh
counting our null values we should now
have uh null null values there we go and
you'll see there's zero null values I
don't know how many times I've been
running a model that doesn't take null
values and it crashes and I just sit
there and look at it trying to why did
that crash it should have worked uh it's
because I forgot to remove the null
values so we've been jumping around a
lot we're going to go back to uh finding
outliers and let's go ahead and bring
that back into our Seaborn and if you
remember we did a box plot earlier uh
this time we're going to do a box plot
just on the price and you can see here
um our price value and we have the
deviation with the two thinner bars on
each side of the main value and then as
we get up here we have all these
outliers in fact we have one way out
here that's um probably a really
expensive high-end car is what we're
looking
at if you were doing um fraud analysis
you would be jumping on all over these
outliers why are these deviation from
the standard what are these people doing
again this is probably like I said a
really high-end expensive car out here
that's what we're looking at and we can
also look at the um box plot for for the
horsepower and we'll put that in down
here and run that and you can see again
here's our horsepower and it just jumps
and there's these really odd huge muscle
cars out here that are
outliers and we're going to jump into
making this a little bit more um as you
start displaying your data or your
information to your shareholders uh
we're going to look at plotting a
histogram for the number of cars per
brand and the first thing we want to go
go ahead and do is we have with our car
go back over here here we go uh we have
our make value counts largest plot um
and we want to do a kind equals bar uh
figure size
105 and right off the bat we jump up
here and we see Chevrolet it's going
against what was it it's um figure the
value counts and we want the largest
value so here's our value counts and
compared to what the different cars are
chevrol puts out a lot of different
kinds of cars I didn't realize that they
made that many cars or different types
and then for readability uh let's go
ahead and add a title number of cars by
make number of cars and make if you had
looked at this the first time you would
have been like well what the heck am I
looking at well we're looking at the
number of cars by make and then you can
see here now we're talking about the
type of cars and the different uh ones
were put out Lotus I guess only had a
few different kinds of cars over there
very high-end
cars
and then as a doing data analytics and
as a data scientist one of the things I
am most interested in is the
relationship between the
variables uh so this is always a place
to start we want to know what's going on
with our variables and how they connect
with each other uh so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to go
ahead and set a figure size because we
want to make sure it fits our graph um
we'll just go ahead and set this one
plot Figure Set to figure size 20110 if
you never m is the map plot Library
which is sitting behind Seaborn uh
whatever is in the PLT this is what's
loaded it's like a canvas you're
painting on so the second you load that
uh pip plot as PLT anything you do to
that is affecting everything on
it uh and then we want to go ahead uh
since we're using
caborn we'll go ahead and create a
variable C for uh relationships or
correspondence and car
docr that's that's a correlation in uh
Seaborn on top of pandas again one line
and you get the whole correlation on
there and because we're working with
Seaborn let's put it into a nice heat
map if you're not familiar with heat
maps that means we're just using color
as part of our um uh setup so we have a
nice
visual and we can see here that the
Seaborn connected to the pandas prints
out a nice chart we'll talk a little bit
about the color here in a second it
prints out a nice chart this is the
chart I look at as a data scientist
these are the numbers I want to look at
uh and we'll just highlight one of them
um here's cylinders versus horsepower
the closer to one the higher the
correlation so 788 pretty high
correlation between the number of
cylinders and how heavy the horsepower
is I'm betting if you looked at the year
versus uh horsepower we just look at
that one here's year and horsepower 314
not as so much but if you combine them
uh you don't actually add them but if
you combine them you'll start to see an
increase in Horsepower per year in
cylinders you could probably get a
correlation there and just like 78 is a
positive correlation uh you might notice
if we look at
cylinders and or let's look at
horsepower and mileage uh so if we go
here to horsepower to mileage you get a
nice um negative we'll do cylinders
that's a bigger number with cylinders to
the miles per gallon it's a minus 6 so
it's a negative correlation the closer
to minus1 the more the negative
correlation
is and then the chart you would actually
show people is a nice heat map this is
all our colors and it's just those
numbers put into a heat map the darker
the color the higher the correlation you
can see straight down the middle um
obviously the year correlates directly
with the year horsepower with horsepower
and so on that's why it's a one the
closer to the one the higher the
correlation between the two pieces of
data
now this is a good introduction uh
pandas goes Way Beyond this most the
functionality in numpy since Panda sits
on it is also in pandas and then it even
has additional features in it and we use
Seaborn pretty extensively sitting on
top over our P plot uh so keep in mind
that our P plot has a ton of other
features in it that we didn't even touch
on in here uh we couldn't even if you
had a sole course in it uh there's just
so many things hidden in there depending
on what your domain you're working on uh
but you can see here here's our caborn
and here's our mat plot Library that's
all our Graphics that we did and then
the Seaborn worked really nicely with
the pandas uh we really like that so
that wraps up our demo part for today
let's learn about data manipulation in R
and here we will learn about deer
package and when we talk about this D
player package it is much faster and
much easier to read than base r so deer
package is used to transform and
summarize tabular data with rows and
columns you might be working on a data
frame or you might be getting in a
inbuilt r data set which can then be
converted into a data frame so we can
get this package deer by just calling in
library function and this can be used
for grouping by data summarizing the
data adding new variables selecting
different set of columns filtering our
data sets sorting it selecting it
arranging it or even mutating that is
basically creating new columns using
functions on existing variables so let's
see how we work with deer now here I can
basically get the package here so I can
just say install. packages deer now we
already see the the package here which
is showing up so I will just select this
one I can do a control enter and that
will basically set up the package
package deer successfully unpacked so
that is done now you can start using
this package by just doing a library
deer and this was built it shows me my
version of R so let's also use a inbuilt
data set that is New York flights 13 so
we can do install. packages and that
will search and get that relevant data
set I can again Call It by using Library
function now once that is done we can
look at some sample data here by just
doing view flights and that shows me the
data in a neat and a Taber format which
shows me year month day departure time
schedule departure time and so on now we
can also do a head to look at some
initial data which can help us in
understanding the data better so what is
this data about how many columns we have
what are the data types or object types
here it shows me how many variables we
have so this is fine now we can start
using deer and in that we can use Save
filter function if we would want to look
in for specific value now here we have
the column as month so I will do a
filter now I'm creating a variable F1
I'm using the filter function on flights
which we already
have and then what we can do is we can
basically look at the month where the
month value is
07 so let's look at that and this one
you can do a view on F1 which shows me
the data wherein you have filtered out
all the data based on month being seven
so this is a simple usage of filter we
can take some other example we may want
to include multiple columns so we can
say F2 filter flights and here we will
say month is equal to 7 day is three and
then look at the value of FS2 if you are
interested in seeing this and that tells
you the month is 7 and days three you
could also look into a more readable
format by using view on F2 and that
gives me my selected result so we are
just extracting in some specific value
we can keep extending this so here we
can say flights is what we would want to
work on I'm using the filter function so
I can straight away instead of creating
a variable then then doing a view I can
also do a view in this way I can just
pass in my filter within the view and
within this I'm saying filter I would
want to look at the flights month being
09 day being 2 and origin being
LGA and then that shows me the value
here and obviously you can scroll and
look at all the columns and if you see
the origin column it shows the selected
value so now we have filtered our our
data based on values in three different
columns now what we can also do is we
can use and or we can use or operators
so I could have done this in a a little
different way so I could have said head
which shows me initial result I will do
a flight So within my head function I'm
passing in this and what does that
contain so you are saying flights and in
this flights data set you would want to
pick up the month being the column so we
use the dollar symbol here we give a
value and I'll say and and I'll again
say flights wherein I will select the
day being two and and and remember when
you talk about and it is going to check
if all the value vales are met true so
then you say flight's origin LGA and you
look at the value so in this way I can
filter out specifically multiple values
by specifying columns now we could have
done it in this way we could have
created a view or we could have assigned
this to a variable and then done a view
on that where we could have selected
month being day and origin or you can be
more specific in specifying all the
columns it makes the code more readable
so let's look at the values and here
you're are looking at head which shows
me based on month day and then you can
look for further columns for other
variables that is origin being LGA now
what we can also do is we can do some
slicing here to select rows by
particular position so I can say slice
and I would want to look at rows 1 to 5
five and I can do this so you can always
assign or look at the view of this I can
just do here so when I did a slide 1 is
to 5 it shows me my entries for 1 to 5
now similarly we can do a slice 5 to 10
and now you're looking at 5 to 10 values
so you can always look at the complete
data and then you can slice out
particular data now mutate is usually a
function which is used when you would
want to apply some variable on a
particular data set and then you would
want to add it to your existing data
frame or you would want to add a new
column so this is where you use mutate
which is mainly used to add new
variables so let's see how you you work
on mutate so it's pretty simple so you
create a variable over delay now I would
want to do a mutate so that it adds a
new column so I'm selecting my data
which is flights I will call the new
column as overall delay and then
basically I can look at overall delay
being arrival delay minus departure
DeLay So let's create this and let's
look at view of this which shows me or
which should show me my new column which
is overall delay which was not in my
original data set so you can anytime do
a head on this one to compare the value
so this one shows me arrival delay and
then there are many other variables what
you can also do is you can do a view and
you could have just look at flights if
you would want to compare so you can
look at the flights and this one would
not have any overall delay column so it
basically shows me 19 columns only what
we see here and if
you do a view on overall delay then that
basically shows me 20 column so we know
that the new column has been added to
this overall DeLay So if you would want
to work with 20 columns you will use
overall delay if you would want to work
with your original data set you will use
flights now you can also use a transmute
function which is used to show only the
new column so we can do a overall delay
and at this time we will say transmute
we will say flights overall delay the
computation remains same but at this
time if I look at view on overall delay
it only shows me the new column so
sometimes we may want to compute result
based on two variables or two columns
and just look at the new value and then
we can decide if we would want to add it
to our existing structure now you can
also use summarize and summarize
basically helps us in getting a
summary based on certain criteria so we
can always do a
summarize and what we can do is we can
look at our data and we can say on what
basis we would want to summarize this
particular data so we can do a summarize
function now summarize on flights I will
say average at time and I would want to
calculate an average so for that I'm
using inbuild function called mean I
will do that on airtime
column so let's look at flights once
again and here we can see there is
arrival time not air time sorry arrival
time and we would want to do some
average on this particular data we would
want to summarize this so what I'll do
is I will use the summarize function I
will say average air time and this one I
will look at mean of air time so let's
see if there is a air time column I
might be let's look at this one arrival
delay and yes we have an air time so we
were actually looking at summarizing
based on air time not the arrival time
so air time is how much time it takes in
air for this particular fight and we
will want to use the trans summarize
function not the transmute so summarize
flights average air time and this one we
will calculate the mean of average air
time and I will also do a na removal
which is I'm saying true so let's do
this and that basically shows me the
average air time is
151 I can also do a total air time where
I'm doing a summation of values or I can
get the standard deviation or I can
basically get multiple values such as
mean
I can say total air time where I'm doing
a summation and then I can look at other
values which is if you would want to put
in standard deviation here you could do
that so let's look at the result of this
summarize and this basically allows me
to get some useful information which is
summarized based on a particular
function such as mean sum standard
deviation
or all three of them now
let's look at grouping by so sometimes
we may be interested in summarizing the
data by groups and that's where we use
the group by function so we can always
use the group by Clause now here we are
taking a different data set so we will
say for example let's look at head of
mty cars and that is basically my data
set on M Mt cars now that shows me the
model of the car it shows me mileage
cylinder P this and your horse power and
various other characteristics or
variables in this particular data set so
here we can say let's do a grouping by
gear so there is a column called gear so
I will call it by gear I will look at my
data set and then what I'm using here
which you see with these percentage and
greater symbol is called called piping
so that basically feeds your previous
data frame into next one so this is
sometimes useful and you can get this by
just saying control shift and M and you
can then use this so we are going to
have piping so I'm saying empty cars now
this is my original data set where I did
a head or I could have done a view on
this one if you would want to see it in
a more readable format and that b
basically shows me the data so we are
using a different data set so I want to
group it by the gear column so I'm going
to call it by gear and this one takes my
data that is empty cars I'm using the
piping and then I'm saying group the
data based on gear column that's done
now let's look at the value of by gear
or you can always do a view so remember
whenever you're doing a group by it is
giving you a internal object where your
data is grouped based on a particular
column so we can look at the values here
you can do a view that shows you your
data grouped based on a particular
column now I can again use the summarize
function where I would want to Now work
on the new one where it was grouped
based on GAR so I'm doing a summarize
and here I'm going to say gear one which
will be having the value of summation on
the gear column and then I'm saying Gear
2 which is mean well you could give some
meaningful names to this and let's look
at the value of this one where we are
basically now looking at the values
which is sum and mean values based on
the
gear similarly we can use look at
different example so we can say by gear
and I'm again using
piping but earlier we had taken gear we
had grouped the data and we called it by
gear so we took our original data set
empty cars but now within this
particular data which was grouped by gar
I will take this data set I will use the
piping and I will summarize it where I
saying within this particular data set I
would want to get the sum or I would
want to get the mean and then you can
look at the values so what you're doing
is you are either looking at your
original data set or you're looking at
the data which was already grouped and
then you can look at the values now here
what we can do is we can Group by
cylinder say might be you are interested
in looking at data which is summarized
based on the cylinder column you can do
that and then for this by cylinder I'm
doing a piping where I'm using the
summarize function and summarizing will
then be done based on the mean values of
the gear column or the horsepower so
let's do this and then you can basically
look at the value at any point you may
want to look at the data set again so
just do ahead and you can look at what
does the value
contain and by cylinder or by gear and
do a head and it gives you the value so
you can always do some summarizing or
grouping in these ways now here we are
going to use sample uncore n function
and Sample
underscore fraction for creating samples
so for this let's take the flights data
set again and we would want to get 15
random values now that is done and it
shows me 15 rows with some random values
from the data what you can also do is
you can do a portion of data by using
sample underscore fraction and here I'll
say slides I'll say 0 4 which will
return 40% of the total data so this can
be useful when you are building your
machine learning where you would want to
split your data into training and test
mightbe you are interested in some
portion of the data so you can do this
which is very useful function and then
you can look at the value of that
now what we can also do is we can use a
range function so like we were doing a
grouping by or we were trying to pull
out a particular column so in the same
way we can use arrange which is a
convenient way of sorting than your base
are sorting so for arrange function
let's do a view based on arrange so we
will work on the flights data set which
we have and here what we would want to
do is we would want to arrange the
flights data set which is based on year
and departure time and we are doing a
view out of it so that basically gives
me the data which is arranged based on
your year and departure time now I can
do a head to give me some highlighting
of that data now the piping operator
what we are using can be used in these
ways also so here I will say DF I will
just assign the data set mty cards to it
let's look at the D F which has
basically your different models you can
obviously look at the head or view of it
to look at useful information we can
also go for nesting options which can be
useful so we are creating a variable
called result here now that has the
arrange function so what does this
arrange function do so when we would
want to use arrange to sort the data so
I would want to sort the data but what
data would I sort so I will use sample n
which will give me some portion of the
data or some sample data now what is
that sample data so here we are using
nesting that is earlier when we did a
sample we just said data and how many
random samples we want but instead of
giving that what we are going to do is
we are going to use filter here now this
filter will work on
DF so filtering will happen BAS based on
the mileage which is greater than 20 I
will say size is five and I would want
to basically arrange this in a
descending order so I'm using the desk
on this particular mileage column by
default it is always ascending so let's
get the result out of this which will
basically show me the mileage details in
a descending order so this is my data
frame and now we can look at the result
what we have created so just do a view
or do a head and look at the view so
here you see mileage where the highest
value is on the
top and we were only interested in five
values in a random sample so that's why
when you did a view it shows your five
values and it shows in a descending
order based on mileage so we have not
only used an inbuilt function we have
not only arranged the data that is we
have sorted the data but we have sorted
the data based on a descending order on
a particular column we have said the
value should be greater than 20 and we
have also said we just need five random
samples now let's look at some other
examples so you can always do a multi-
assignment so I can say filter wherein
I'm going to use DF which was assigned
empty cars I'm going to say mileage
should be greater than 20 then I say B
which is going to get a sample out of a
and I just want five random values so
let's look at that so we have B which is
going to get a set of five values from a
now I will create a result variable
which will arrange B which is sample
data in a descending order now let's
look at the result of of this and that
basically shows me what we were seeing
earlier so you can do a multi-
assignment where you can create a
variable get a sample out of it and then
basically whatever is that result you
can arrange that or sort that in a
descending or by default descending
order so same thing we can do it using
pipe operator so piping so here I will
say result I'm passing in my DF that's
the data set I'm using piping and which
basically tells what you need to do on
this particular data set so I'm going to
filter out the data based on mileage 50
sorry mileage 20 then I'm going to push
that or forward it to get the random
sample and whatever is this random
sample is going to be pushed so you are
arranging this in a descending order so
this is one more way of doing it and
then basically you can look at the
result so these are some simple examples
where you can use your D plier with
multip assignments or using your nesting
to filter out the data you can also do a
range which is to sort the data you can
get some random samples out of it you
can summarize the data you can also
summarize the data based on one or two
or multiple columns and you can use some
inbuilt functions to summarize the data
based on some functions which are
applied on the variables or on the
columns you can transmute it where you
would be interested in only looking at
one column you can mutate it where you
want to add a new column you can slice
it and you can give the conditions where
you can say and on or to filter out the
data so what we can also do is on this
particular data set which we have say
for example DF where I have my data
let's look at this one and if I just do
a DF at this point it shows me my my
data set and if you would be interested
only in particular column then your deer
also allows you to either we can do a
filter or we can simply do a select now
for selecting we can
choose uh our data so for example I'll
say DF underscore I'm interested in
mileage I'm interested in Horsepower
might be I'm interested in your
cylinders in this
and for this one what I can do is when I
would want to do a select I can
basically say selected DF let's call it
some name I can say control shift M
which is for piping and then basically
what you can do is you can do a select
and you can choose your columns so I was
interested in mileage I was interested
in Hors power I was interested in
cylinder and here what I'm doing is I'm
using a select where I can look at the
new data frame so let's do this and uh
I'm sorry here we will have to give it
DF this is where you are passing in your
data yeah now this one is done and we
can look at the value of this one by
just doing a DF or head on
EF underscore mileage horsepower
cylinder and look at the selected result
so you can be looking at selective
columns I could have done this filter
but filter will always look for a
condition say your mileage is greater
than 20 or might be your cylinders are
more than four or something else but
when you do a select you are selecting
specific columns so view always gives
you all the columns head gives you
highlight but then select can be useful
when we are interested in looking at
only specific data so this is how you
can use deer for manipulation for your
data transformation for basically
filtering out the data by selecting
particular data and then working on it
so similarly there is one more package
called tidd and we'll see how we can use
data manipulation done using your tidd
package Let's uh learn about the tidd
package which makes it easy to tidy your
data and this basically helps you
creating a more cleaner data so which is
easy to visualize and model now this
comes with the mainly four functions so
you have gather which makes your data
wide or it makes white data longer so
that is basically used to stack up
multiple columns
you have spread function which makes
long data wider that is stacking the
data together or stack if you would want
to unstack the data to data and you are
talking about data which has same
attributes and then you spread can
spread the data across multiple columns
you have separate which is function
which splits single column into multiple
columns and to complement that you have
one more function which is unite and
that combines multiple columns into
single columns so these are four main
functions which are used in your tidd r
package so let's look how we work with
this so let me bring up my R Studio here
now for this first is let me just clean
up my screen here doing a control l so I
will install the package it is already
installed but we can just do a control
enter and then I can say do you want to
restart or prior to re install to
install I'll say
okay and it is basically going to get
the
package now it says package T TI yr that
is TDR has been successfully unpacked
let's use that package with using our
library
function and that was built under R
version
3.6 now I can basically start using
these functions so for example here we
are creating a data frame so let's say n
is
10 and then we basically would say we
will call it white now that's the
variable name I'm using the data do
frame function I'm saying ID which will
be 1 to n so that will take the values
from 1 to 10 and then these are the
values which
have 10 entries so this is a vector
Phase 1 Phase 2 phase three let's create
a data frame out of it now that's done
we can have a look at our data frame by
just doing a view wide and that shows me
the ID column and it has ph. 1 pH do2
and ph. 3 now we can use our function so
for example we can work with gather that
is reshaping the data from wide format
to Long format and basically you can say
stacking up multiple columns so let's
see how we do that here I'll call it
long I'm working on wide I'm using the
piping functionality and then I'm using
gather so this one I will say what will
be the data which I will use so we are
using wide as a data frame then I'm
saying response time so that will be
basically one more column and then you
have your columns which you would want
to basically stack so I'm saying from
phase one to phase three so let's do
this and once this is done let's have a
look at our variable long so this one
shows me that I have I have an ID column
I have the response time column and I
have the face column which we mentioned
and that basically has all the values
stacked in so you have ph. one pH do2
and pH do3 so all the columns are being
stacked here so all my data so now I
have totally 30 entries in this one so
this is basically using your gather
function now sometimes we may want to
use a separate function now separate
function is basically splitting a single
column into multiple columns so which we
would want to use when multiple
variables are captured in a single
variable column okay so let's look at an
example of this one so let's say long
separate that's what we will call we
will work on this long which has all the
data stacked in as the columns we
selected then I'm saying separate I want
the face column and then I would say
when I separate the columns what are my
column names now I could also give a
separator by giving a comma and then
mentioning the separator if that is
required so let's do this now once this
is done let's have a look at our long
separate so what we see here is the
column which we used so we were doing a
face column and that was to be split and
we wanted to split it into Target and
number so that's what we see here so you
have face being split into Target and
number and then you have the response
time so this is how you use the separate
function now there is also something
called as unite function which is
basically a complimenting of separate
function so it takes multiple columns
and combines the elements to a single
column so for example here we will call
it long unite and we will take long
separate which was separating the data
we want to unite so we will take phas
tar Target number and we want to have a
separator between them so let's
basically do this and now let's look at
the result of this unite so you see you
have the face and Target merge together
so you have ph. one the separator is dot
as we have mentioned and we have United
multiple columns so this is one more
function of your tidd which helps you
basically uh tidy up your data or put it
in a particular way now then you have
your spread function and this is
basically for unstacking so that is if
you have if you would want to convert a
stack to data or if you would want to
unstack the data which is of same
attributes spread can be used so that
you can spread the data across multiple
columns so it will take two columns say
key and value and spread it into
multiple columns so it makes long data
wider so we can look at this one we will
say long unite I'm using the piping I
will use the spread function I'll work
on the face column and response time and
let's do this and then let's do a view
on this so it tells me our data is back
in the shape as it was in the beginning
so these are four functions which are
very helpful when we work with tidd
package so let's learn about
visualization and here we will learn
about R which can be used for your
visualization now one thing which we
need to understand is because of our
ability to see patterns which is highly
developed we can understand the data
better if we can visualize it so the
efficient way or effective way to
understand what is in our data or what
we have understood in our data we should
or we can use graphical displays that is
your data visualization so there are
actually two types of data
visualizations so you have exploratory
data visualization which helps us to
understand the data and then you have
explanatory visualization which helps us
to share our understanding with others
so when you talk about r r provides
various tools and packages to create
data
visualizations and which can be used for
both kind of data analysis or both kind
of visualizations so when you talk about
exploratory data visualization the key
is to keep all the potentially relevant
details together now the objective when
we talk about explor data analysis is to
help you see what is in your data and
the main question is how much details
can we in interpret now when you talk
about different functions which we see
here such as plot which is more for a
generic uh plotting you have bar plot
which is used to plot data using
rectangular bars or you can say creating
bar charts you have histogram or hist
function to create histograms where you
look at the
frequency of uh the data or basically
used to look at the central tendency of
the data you have box plot which is used
to represent data in the form of
quartiles you have GG plot which is a
package which enables the user to create
sophisticated visualizations with the
little code using the grammar of
graphics and then you have plotly or
plot ly it creates interactive web-
based graphs via the open-source
JavaScript graphing library now before
we see some examples here let's also
talk about when you talk about plotting
let's also try to understand what kind
of plots you can have and what kind of
techniques you have so let me open up my
R Studio here now for example I can pull
out a particular data set and let's look
at this one so here I can look at all
the panes and that shows me the
information now what I can do is I can
inst install and get the inbuilt data
sets and then I can simply do a plot
wherein I am doing a plot on Chu data
set so let's see what does that show it
summarizes the relationship between four
variables in chick weight data frame
which is in ours built-in data set
package now from these plots we can see
for example weight varies systematically
over time you can can also see that
chicks were assigned to four different
diets now when we talk about explanatory
data analysis or visualization that
shows others what we found in the data
this means we need to make some
editorial decisions what features we
would want to highlight for
emphasis what features are distracting
or confusing and you want them to be
eliminated right so there are different
ways of doing it now when you talk about
your Graphics or visualizations you have
I would say three different types or you
can say four so you have the base
Graphics which is easiest to learn now
here we are having an example of Base
Graphics where I can use the base
Graphics I can get a um data set using
library then I can simply create using
plot function to a generate a simple
scatter plot of calories with sugar from
us serial data frame in the mass package
and then I can give it a title so this
is basically a simple example of Base
Graphics now you also have what we call
as grid Graphics which is powerful set
of modules for building other tools now
you also have latest Graphics which is
general purpose system based on grid
graphics and then you have your GG plot
2 which implements grammar of graphics
and is based on grid Graphics so you
have different ways now here since I
already have used library and I have the
data set I can just do a x so I can
assign the sugar related values to X and
calories related value to Y then I can
use one more which is Library function
and calling in Grid now I can basically
use functions such as push view Port if
I would want to create a plot using your
grid Graphics to create the similar kind
of plot which we created using base
Graphics but this will give you much
more power than base Graphics it will
have uh a steep learning curve but it is
usually useful so I can do this where
I'm saying push view Port then I can
basically say I would want to have a
data view Port I would say different
functions of your grid package so I'm
saying rectangle you have x axis y AIS
given some points here
and then basically you can add details
to the graph by giving the names to the
columns and you can basically create a
simple grid Graphics based plot here now
there are different other options which
we can use to create plots now before we
go into understanding how you create
plots let me just give you a brief on
what are the different kind of plots and
how they can be used so here we will
look at these different different plots
now for example we have a bar chart
which is a graph which shows comparisons
across discrete categories so you have x
axis which will show the categories
being compared and Y AIS which
represents a measured value and height
of the bars are proportional to measured
values Now to create different kind of
charts you can use ggplot which is a
package for cre graphs in R it is
basically method of thinking about and
decomposing complex graphs into logical
subunits and that is a part of Tidy
worse ecosystem so it takes each
component of graph axises you can give
scales you can give colors you can give
the objects and you can build graphs on
particular data you can modify each of
those components in a way that's more
flexible and user friendly you can if
you are not providing details for the
components then ggplot will use sensible
defaults and this basically makes it a
powerful and a flexible tool now here
are different options when you use your
GG plot such as you can use Gom or what
we call as geometry objects to form the
basis of different type of graphs for
bar charts you have for line graphs you
have Scatter Plots that is underscore
point you have underscore box plot for
box plots you have CAU tile for
continuous X wlin for richer display of
distribution and Jitter for small data
so here is some simple example where I
would not go into too many details here
but you can just have a look at this one
where we are using Library function to
get the ggplot 2 package then basically
we would want to look into the mileage
data we would want to look at the
structure of it and then we can
basically get the Tidy worse package
finally we can create a bar chart using
gomore bar and we can basically also
mention what would be in x-axis now you
can also give different colors to
basically add more meaning to your data
you could also go for stacked bar charts
so here we are actually telling GG plot
to map the data in the drive column to
fill the aesthetic so here I am giving
aesthetic access class and I'm saying
what is the data we need to have and
then we are using gomore bar so you can
also have dodged bar in your GG plot
that is not bar charts which are stacked
but next to each other and you can
create that by using your position as
position _ Dodge okay now you can
obviously use your different packages
which are inbuilt and you can create
your bar charts
and you have other kind of graphs such
as line graph which is basically a type
of graph that displays information as a
series of data points connected by
straight line segments such as this one
and for this one we are using if you see
gomore line now you can also create a
scatter plot which is a
two-dimensional data visualization that
uses points to graph the values of two
different variables one in on x axis one
on y- axis like what we saw in base
Graphics example and they are mainly
used if you would want to assess the
relationship or lack of relationship
between two variables and you also have
histogram which I mentioned is mainly to
look at the distribution of a data to
look at the central tendency of the data
basically looking at your um large
amount of data or for a single variable
you would be interested in saying where
is more data found in terms of frequency
where is lesser data found in the graph
how close the data is towards its uh mid
point or what we call as mean median
mode so you can use histogram where you
can categorize the data in what we call
as bins so these are some Basics on
different kind of graphs now we can look
at some examples and see how that works
so what we were seeing is some quick
examples of Base Graphics or grid
Graphics now here let's do an example of
Pi chart for different products and unit
sold so you want to create a graph for
this first let's create a vector and
pass in the value here now I can also
create labels which I would want to
assign to these values and then
basically I can plot the chart by saying
Pi so that's the kind of chart which I
would want to create and I would say the
data would be X and and labels so let's
do this and that shows me a simple pie
chart now I can also give main details
here so instead of just doing a pi x
comma labels I can say what is the main
and then what kind of coloring it should
follow so this is the way you can create
a
simple uh plot now I can also find out
what is the percentage and then
basically I would be interested in
plotting the pie chart which takes X
which takes the labels which will be the
percentage which we are calculating here
by doing a round function and then you
can basically give details to your graph
you can say what color it follows you
can basically look at the legend where
it needs to be in your
chart what are the values and then
basically fill up the colors so let's
run this one and that shows me the
percentage which was calculated and it
gives me the details and we can always
have a look at our plot now if you would
want to go for a 3D pie chart then you
can get the package which is plot Trix
let's use that by calling in the library
function let's pass in some data to X
and let's give some values or labels
which will make more meaning to the data
and then let's plot the 3D graph so I'm
saying p 3D here where I'm using X and
labels then I'm basically doing an
explode which will basically control how
your graph looks like and basically give
the values so it also takes the title
when you say Main and by chart of
countries now let's create data for
graph so again we are having a variable
here we are create using the C function
creating a vector and then let's create
a histogram for this one where I would
say xlab what would be your data around
x axis what is the color what is the
border and here I'm creating a simple
histogram which as I discussed earlier
will always show your values on the xais
and Y AIS is more of frequency and then
you can look at the set of values and
what is their frequency and we can
basically use this histogram for
exploratory data analysis look at the
data try to understand what is the
central tendency of your data values now
we can also give some limits by using
the X liim and Y Lim and then I can also
specify what is the limit so we have
given some values here wherein we have
said your X limit is 0 to 40 and Y limit
is 0 to 5 now if you compare this with
the previous one which we had created
this one based on the frequency had
taken the limits but we can assign
limits explicitly by giving this and
then create a histogram which makes more
meaning now let's take another data set
that is air quality let's view this to
see what does that data contain so you
have ozone solar wind temperature month
and the day so this is the kind of
information we have in the air quality
now let's use the plot function to draw
a scatter plot where as I mentioned you
would be interested in analyzing
variables and see what is the
relationship between them so to plot a
graph between ozone and wind values so
we will say plot we will say the data
which is air quality from that I would
be interested in the ozone column or
ozone field and the wind field I can
create a plot based on this now I can
also be saying what should be the color
what is the type of the data which you
would want to create and you can look at
the in information so you can create a
histogram you can create a a scatter
plot to basically understand the data
better and then infer some information
from that data so let's take the air
quality data set itself without
specifying any particular column and you
can create a plot which shows me all the
different values which you have in the
data and it basically shows you the
difference this is more of an example
like what we did for chick weight where
we did a base Graphics now you can
assign labels to the plot so that is
when you are creating a plot you can say
air quality you will say ozone and then
that's your ozone concentration you have
your ylab which is the number of
instances you have what is the title
ozone levels in New York City what is
the color so these are the details what
we have given with our plot function and
let's look at the data so it just tells
me that this is the ozone
concentration uh the number of instances
for you have and you are looking at the
data now we could also create a
histogram by picking up a particular
column that is such as solar from your
air quality and that basically shows me
the frequency of solar values and we can
then try to find out what is the mid
what is the mean what is the standard
deviation and so on you can also look at
your histogram and try to understand if
it is left skewed and right skewed so we
can do that now here let's get the
temperature out from this particular
data set let's create a histogram on
temperature and that basically shows me
the frequency of the temperature values
and what values have the most frequency
or most occurrence now you can create a
histogram with
labels so let's do that with the limit
and then let's also use text to
basically given the values which also
takes the values and for each set of
frequency or each set of values it gives
me the labels now you can have a
histogram with non-uniform width so you
could do that by doing a hist function
and then passing in your temperature you
can say what will be the main what is
the title what will be your
xlab it will tell you a limit around
x-axis what is the color what is the
Border what are the brakes you would
want to have for your bars and you can
simply create a histogram using this so
This basically takes the breakes which
we have given such as 55 to 60 60 to 70
70 to 75 and so on so this is basically
creating a histogram with non uniform
width and it purely depends on the kind
of values what you have now you can also
create a box plot which sometimes helps
us in understanding the the data
quartiles also understanding our
outliers so you can create multiple box
plots based on the data from air quality
so we'll select all the data and then
we'll do some slicing on the data so
let's create a box plot which tells me
the values and if you look at these
points here like single dots these are
basically your outliers we can learn
about that more in later sections so you
can use your GG plot to library to
analyze a particular data set so for
that we will first use the install do
packages and get ggplot
2 so it says do you want to restart R
and I can say yes so let it get the
package I think the package was already
there and
now let's look at using ggplot 2 so for
that I have the library
function and let's do a attach where I'm
getting the data set which is empty cars
now then I will create a variable P1 I
will use GG plot I will pass in my data
I'll give the Aesthetics what is the
columns which you would be interested in
and then you are using gomore boxplot to
basically create a plot which gives me
the box plot for the values here and
this is based on the cylinders which is
there in your data so we can always look
at what does our data contain and what
kind of values or features are available
in the data now let's create a box plot
we will also use the coordinate function
and that basically gives me based on the
data so I've changed the coordinates now
if you you look at the previous one
where we created a plot we had mileage
on the Y AIS and cylinders on the
x-axis now I did a coordinate flip and
that's like your transpose function so
you have created the box plot but you
have just flipped the coordinates you
can create a box plot and then say fill
which is the factor of cylinder so that
can be used to fill up the values in
your box plot
now what we can also do is we can create
factors so we have learned about factors
earlier which is usually used to work on
categorical variables so here let's
create a factor which is empty cars gear
you have am you have cylinder and if you
look at the factors which we have
created we have passed our data what is
the field or the column we are
interested in what is the level of
values there and what are the labels for
those values right so we have learned
about factors you can always look into
the previous section and learn more
about factors now let's create a scatter
plot by using the GG plot function again
we will use the data as empty cars I
will go for mapping option and then I
will give my Aesthetics that is what
would be x what would be your Y and you
also would want to use what kind of
function you're using so let's go for
gome point point and that basically
helps me in creating a scatter plot now
you can create a scatter plot by factors
so here we will say GG plot so notice in
all of these cases depending on the kind
of data you have depending on the kind
of plot you are interested in you will
use the GG plot and then basically a
function with that or the inbuilt
package so here I'm saying data is empty
cars I'm going for mapping which
basically will take the values for your
X and Y what is the color and the
coloring will be done based on the
factor values now if you remember
factors will obviously have some levels
and uh those levels will basically help
you in differentiating between your
categorical variables so I'm saying as.
Factor on cylinder and then I'm using
gome point to basically create this
scatter plot so let's do this
and I can look at the values of this one
so it says must be there is an error
with says must at least one color from
the Hue pallet so let's look at that one
so the error which we were facing when
we gave color as the factor values was
because when you look at these factors
which were created with some labels if
we look at the values of these it tells
me there are any values in that
particular column similarly your gear or
similarly you can completely look at the
complete data set it tells me cylinder
you have am you have G now these have
some we have created some labels but
these have na values so what we can do
is we can create a scatter plot as we
did earlier by giving the Aesthetics and
that's a simple scatter plot wherein I'm
also using Gom point so that I can have
these points by defaults or with
defaults you can also give a color
specific basically if you would want to
have different kind of data in the same
plot or I can create Scatter Plots by
different sizes by giving a size or I
can give a color and size and that's
again one way in which you can create
your Scatter Plots now let's also see
how you can visualize one more data set
which is
MPG so I can also do it in this way
where I said ggplot two and then passing
look at the data set what we have here
you can just do a view on this to see
what my data contains if the fields have
any na values if that's going to affect
your plotting so now what we can do is
we can create a bar plot or a bar chart
so I'm saying GG plot the data would be
as we have given in previous lines that
is ggplot 2 MPG then I will say what
should be in my Aesthetics and what kind
of chart are you going to create so I'm
saying gomore bar so that's my bar chart
and that has basically your class and
count now you can create a stacked bar
chart where your information is stacked
in the same bars and we are still using
the same data we are going for
Aesthetics which is class and then when
you say gome bar which creates your
stack bar we will use fill which is
drive and we can always go back and look
at our data for example you can always
look into this so you have the drive
column here and you are also working on
this complete data set so let's go ahead
and create a stacked bar chart and that
basically gives me the information where
you have the drive information which is
stacked here now you can do a Dodge by
giving the position as Dodge so we we
are still going to go for a stack chart
but this time the bars will be next to
each other and that can also be done
which is very useful you can use this by
using geom point where you're mapping
and you're specifying what are your
Aesthetics so we were creating a scatter
plot now you can also use or give more
details where you can say color can be
based on the class and we have different
classes and based on that my my points
have been colored now you can also use a
plot ly or plotly Library so let's
install this one I will say yes for
example let it basically restart so that
all my packages are updated then I can
access that package using Library
function and then create a variable to
which you are assigning your plot _ ly
plot so data is empty cars what will be
your xais what will be your y axis and
details on your marker which we have
given wherein I will give a list which
is size color which is a combination and
then you have your line what kind of
color it will have and what will be the
width so this is where I'm going to use
plot
ly and let's look at this
plot so it basically gives me some
information now we see some warnings
which are getting generated but there is
you don't need to worry about that so
you can look at the packages what you
have and what options you're using so
similarly we can create one more plot
using plot ly and look at the values of
those so that's a plot with a trend
which explains me about my data so this
is a simple small tutorial on
understanding or uh how you can have
your graphics or
visualization used to understand your
data obviously there are much more
examples much more ways in which you can
pass into your plot functions or your GG
plot and the inbuilt packages which are
available in R for your visualization
now that could be for explorat data
analysis or explanat data analysis so
try these graphs and see if you can
change these options and try or create
new visualization
good morning and good evening everyone
so welcome to this session where we will
learn on time series analysis using our
programming language so this is
basically a mini project where we will
look at time series data and how we can
analyze it visualize it to basically
find some important information or
gather insights from the data now when
you talk about time series analysis time
series is basically any data set where
your values are measured at different
points in time so when you talk about
time series data data is usually
uniformly spaced at a specific frequency
for example hourly weather measurements
you have daily counts of website visits
monthly sales total and so on so when
you talk about time series that can also
be irregularly spaced and sporadic for
example timestamp data in computer
systems event log or history of 911
emergency calls now when we work with
time series data for example here I'm
taking a energy data set we can see how
techniques such as time-based indexing
res sampling rolling windows can help us
explore variations in electricity demand
and renewable energy Supply over time
now here we will look at some aspects of
this data set which I'm considering so
there is this is open Power Systems data
set and here is the data set I have we
can look at the data set now this is in
a simple format it has time it basically
has values for consumption and then you
have data for wind and solar and wind
plus solar so in certain cases you have
only the date and the consumption but
then if we scroll down we will also find
data for wind so solar wind plus solar
and so on so this is a Time series data
set which we would want to work on
sometimes you may also have the data
collected which just does not have the
time but it may also have time stamp
that is it would have say hour minutes
and seconds and that can also be worked
upon so let's consider this data set and
let's work on this project where we will
Analyze This Time series data set now
here we can work on this time series
data we can basically create some data
structures out of it such as data frames
we can do some time based indexing we
can visualize the data we can look at
the seasonality in the data look at some
frequencies and also do some Trend
detection now when you talk about this
data set it has electricity production
and consumption which is reported as
daily totals in gigawatt hours and here
are The Columns of the data which I was
just showing you so you have data you
have consumption you have wind you have
solar and wind plus solar so this is the
data we have and we will basically
explore say electricity consumption and
production in Germany which has varied
over time so some of the questions which
we can answer here is when is
electricity consumption typically
highest and lowest how do wind and solar
power production vary with seasons of
the year what are the long-term trends
in electricity consumption solar power
and wind power how do wind and solar
power production compared with
electricity consumption and how has this
ratio changed over time we can also do
wrangling or cleaning of this data or
pre-processing of data and create a data
frame and then we can visualize this now
let's see how do we do that so I will
open up my R studio and let's look at
the data set so here is the data set now
I'm picking it up from my machine you
can also pick it up from GitHub so all
the data sets or similar data sets can
be find in my GitHub repository and here
I can look in the data sets you will
find lot of different data sets here
there are some time series data sets
such as power I can search for power or
you have basically
coal or you have
this
opsd Germany daily data set and there
are many other data sets which you can
work on now to get the documentation on
this project you can also look in my
GitHub repository and you can search for
repositories and then basically you can
look in data science and R and here
there is a project folder where I've
have given the documentation sample data
set and also your time series analysis
related document this is also the code
which you can directly Import in your R
studio and you can practice or work on
this project so let's see how does that
work so first thing is we will create a
data frame from this data set now here
if you see I'm using header as true so
that it understands the heading of each
column I'm also giving row. names and
I'm specifying date so there is this
date column in the data set as I showed
you earlier let's look at it again so
you have date consumption wind solar
wind plus solar so you can suggest that
date should become the index column
which can be useful so you can do this
now let's just create this let's look at
what does this data frame contain and
here if you see it shows me some data
which has
been now as a part part of this data
frame structure it starts with
consumption wind solar wind plus solar
and if you see this one is becoming my
index column so I can always do a head
and look at part of the data frame using
head or tail so look at the first
records so let's see this now that shows
me the head data I can also do a tail
and look at the ending values so if you
closely see here we have wind solar wind
do solar and that basically has na
values so there are missing values but
let's look at the tail and that tells me
that there is some data available for
wind and solar and wind solar now we can
always look in a tabular format using
View and we can look at the data so this
shows me that there are values in these
columns we see na values but if I really
scroll down I can see some Val values
which would be available for wind and
solar and wind solar so I can just use
view now I can look at the dimensions of
this particular object and that tells me
there are 400 uh
4,384 rows and four columns you can
always look at the structure that is
check the data type of each column which
can be very useful so if I see here I
don't see the date column because date
column was considered as an index which
can useful but I also look at my other
columns they are of the num types so
that's the data type for each attribute
or each column here now we would be
interested in looking at this date
column so let's look at the data type of
this date column now if I try to do this
this will show me that this is null
because date as a column does not exist
because we created it as an index so if
I look at row names and then I search
for my data show me the index column or
row. names it tells me these are the
values that's the date column which we
are seeing here now we can access a
specific row by just doing a my data and
give the index value or row name value
so let's look at that and that shows me
based on this index you're looking at
the value you can obviously search for a
different date something like this you
can can also pass in a vector and you
can give range of values so that is 0 1
2006 to 4 of January and we can look at
this one so it shows me these are the
values so here actually I'm not giving a
range but I'm just selecting multiple
values from row. names now we already
know that in R you have a summary
function so you can always do a summary
and that gives you for each each column
it gives you minimum first quartile
median mean third quartile and maximum
values so we are looking at consumption
we are looking at wind solar and wind do
solar now this is good but then if I
would want to really visualize the data
access the data do some analysis then it
would be good to take all the colums and
then we can later decide to change the
data type of say date column if you want
to use it so earlier I was using date as
row. names or the name of the rows or
index what you call in any other
programming language so here I will just
use my data set and I'll say header is
true I'm calling it my data 2 let's look
at the data and this one shows me five
columns where in My First Column is the
date consumption wind solar and so on
now looking at the structure so let's
look at the data type so it tells me
that if now I'm interested in looking at
the date column from my data 2 Data
frame it tells me it is a factor with
4384 levels and these are the values so
it is not in a datetime format it's a
factor now what we can do is we can
convert this into a date format how do
we do that so let's have a variable X
and and I'm going to use as. date
function and I'm going to pass in my
date column so that's assigned to X now
let's look at the head of X and it shows
me the values we will also see what kind
of class it is and we will look at the
structure of X so class already says it
is date type and look at the structure
so it shows me the format now we have
converted this column or column related
value into X now how do I basically
extract values out of it or make it a
part of data frame so first I will use
so all once it has been converted in
date format I will go for as. numeric
and here I will create a variable called
ear and I will just do a format on X
which is basically of date type and then
I'm saying percentage y so that will get
me the ear component out of this let's
look at the values that shows me ear
component
now similarly we can get the month out
of this and then basically look at the
month values we can get the day out of
it and we can get the day component now
if I look at my data 2 which we had
created earlier this basically had date
consumption wind solar wind solar so
what I can do is I can add these
extracted columns such as year month Day
to my data frame using a a cbind that is
column bind and I will assign it to my
data 2 again so let's do this and now if
you look at head it shows me date so
that should be date format consumption
now this one might not be date format
but we'll see you have consumption wind
solar and we have extracted the year
month and day which can help us for
group buy we can do some aggregations we
can do a plotting and we can do various
things by these additional columns
now let's look at first three rows here
so I'll say 1 is to three for my data
two and that shows me some data here you
can always do ahead and look at the
sample of data so that basically shows
me month day your columns and then you
have your date now what we can do is we
would want to visualize this data we
would want to basically understand the
consumption now as I said if we want to
visualize the data say for example I
want this which is consumption of data
over years and this one is in terms of
gigawatts per hour as we were mentioning
here gigawatt hours so if I would want
to create this visual to basically
understand the pattern of the data how
do we do it so we can you create a line
plot of full-time series of Germany's
electricity consumption using the plot
method now how do we do that so here one
of the option is I can straight away use
the plot method I can then say what
would be in my x axis what would be on
my Y axis what would be the type of
graph I would want to plot what is my
name on x- axis y AIS and this is the
simplest way so I'm saying my data 2 I'm
extracting the year column and here I'm
taking the consumption so let's create a
plot
and here if you see we are looking at a
plot we do see some tick times and we
see that the data has been divided with
every two years so from 2006 onwards to
2016 but then really this data does not
give me uh you know a very useful way of
looking at the r or understanding it
might be what I can do is I can use the
same way but I can give apart from
x-axis and Y AIS I can say the limits
that is X limit is 2006 to 2018 and Y
limit is from 800 to 1700 so we can do
this and let's look at this again this
is a plot but it really does not help me
in visualizing and understanding the
data so what are the better options I
can go for multiple plots in a window as
of now we are just sticking to one plot
in window so if you would want to have
multiple plots plots you can always
change the value here and make it two or
three that will say how many rows and
how many columns so as of now we will
just keep it as it is par MF row now if
I would want to plot I can straight away
give the column name so I am interested
in getting the consumption now I can
just do a plot I'll say my data 2 and I
will choose the second column which is
consumption which we saw here from our d
data so consumption was the second
column so I can just do a plot in a
straightaway way without mentioning your
xaxis y AIS limits and so on and if you
look at this this one is giving me a
pattern now here I am looking at um
x-axis Y axis which is not really named
we do not have a name to this graph and
we are looking at the data it does show
me some kind of pattern but mightbe we
can make make it more meaningful so I
can do it this way where I say my data
second column let's give axis as ear
xaxis y- axis is consumption now that
has changed the x-axis and y axis now I
can also give some more details I can
say type should be line I have the line
width I'm saying color is blue and let's
do this so this looks more meaningful
might be shows a wavering pattern of
consum ion over years I can also give a
limit of x that is 0 to 2018 and that
basically shows me the range now we can
change that and we can be more specific
and saying X limit should be 2006 to
2018 and let's look at this now this one
once you have given a proper limit it
shows the line graph and it shows what
was the consumption in 2006 and over a
period till 2018
I can then use any of these options are
fine but it depends on what and whom you
are presenting the data or what kind of
analysis you're doing so I can do a plot
I can choose column second xlab which is
xaxis y AIS type is line width giving X
limit y limit and then I'm giving a
title to this which is consumption graph
and then basically you're looking at the
line graph now those are the options
which you can do either you could be
very specific or you could just give
your column which you want to plot or
obviously make it more meaningful by
giving all the details now what we can
do is if we would want to look at this
data and understand it better rather
than just looking at a simple line I can
take the log values so here I'm saying
log of my data 2 second column so I'm
taking log values of consumption and I'm
taking the difference of logs so I can
say difference and then you can
basically increase or decrease this by
multiplying it by some number so rest
Remains the Same I'm changing the color
and let's look at this plot and you see
this basically is giving me a better
pattern which makes meaning here we see
the log values so this is you are using
a simple plot
function in R you can also use GG plot
now for the that we can install the
ggplot package it's already there in my
machine so I'll say no I will access
this by using the library ggplot
2 and now I can use ggplot to plot so
the way you specify here you can say my
data 2 that's the data frame I'm saying
type as o and when I'm saying line I am
basically going to use x axis which is
here Y is consumption and let's look at
this plot so again we are back to the
one which we were doing earlier really
does not make any sense gives us some
data but then really does not give me
enough information I can in my
Aesthetics I can say XS ear Ys
consumption I can do a grouping and then
I can give line and plot so again we
have some information but really does
not help me right now let's look at
other example so I'm just doing the same
thing here and I'm looking at line type
being tached I'm using the GG plots
other method such as gome line and gome
point to give me more information and if
I look at the plot it does give me data
it tells me what are the different
values it gives me some kind of pattern
but I would still prefer the way we were
doing with plot now we can change the
color and obviously add details to it so
what we see is when you use the plot
method which I did earlier it was
choosing pretty good tick locations that
is every 2 years and labels the years
for the x-axis which was helpful right
but with these data points which we were
seeing here or say for example this
one or say this one or say this one we
are looking at some data but then that
really is quite crowded and it is hard
to read you can look at the values but
then it really does not give you enough
information so we can go for plot method
but then we will see how we can consider
different data now if I would want to
plot the solar and wind time series so
let's see how do we do that so wind
column is what I'm interested in so
first thing is it was always good to
find out the minimum and the maximum
values in in every column so I'm saying
minimum I'm saying let's put in here my
data
2 and then let's look at the values so
we are looking at the columns we know
consumption is the second column wind is
the third column and you have solar is
the fourth and this one is the fifth so
let's say let's find out the minimum of
each of these columns which we would
want to plot so let's say minimum of
data third column
and here I'm also saying remove the na
values because we do not want to
consider the na values so let's look at
the minimum that shows me 5.7 757 what
is the maximum value it is 826 so that
also helps me in giving a limit if I
want to plot wind on y AIS I can give a
y limit from 5 to
850 consumption wise let's find out the
minimum from second column and maximum
and similarly for solar find the minimum
and maximum and wind plus solar minimum
and maximum so this will be helpful when
you would want to plot multiple graphs
or give some limits so that's fine now
for multiple plots as I said instead of
having one plot let's plot consumption
and wind and solar and try to see a
pattern so I can say par function and I
will say three rows and one column so
now when I start plotting you will see
you will have multiple plots in one
single window so let's see how we do it
so here let's look at plot one so this
one is consumption as we did earlier and
let's look at the data so that gives me
some data you can always do a zoom and
you can look at the data you can
basically expand this graph or you can
reduce this graph to see what kind of
pattern we have in consumption similarly
we can basically choose date being xaxis
my consumption being Y axis right so
this is being more specific because here
we have a range but it really does not
give me enough information so I will
basically give xaxis y AIS I will give
the name that is daily totals and then I
will basically give consumption color
and Y limit based on my minimum and
maximum limits so let's do this and now
we can look at the data here so let's
see this data makes a little more
meaning because we are looking at the
dates and let me do a zoom so it shows
me all the dates it shows me the data
points it shows me how the data pattern
is changing for consumption now this is
for consumption so what we can do is we
can also extract specific data so if you
see here I have done some testing where
I am saying okay I would want to get a
date specifically I would want to
extract some Valu so we are looking at
the date column but if you remember we
did not change the data type we just
changed the data type of date column we
extracted year mon month out of it it it
would be good if we can convert a column
into date time format and put that in
our data frame now let's look at the
plot two this is mainly for your uh
column which should be consumption and
wind and solar so here I see it is solar
data and I can plot this one to see how
it looks like and that tells me from
2006 onwards we have some pattern I can
be more specific where I say I would be
giving date and then the column for
solar xaxis y AIS what is the type what
is the Y limit and what is the color it
is always good to specify your X and Y
AIS given name rather than let it
automatically pick up now this makes
more meaning because it shows me some
dates similarly we can do for wind so
either you do it just by giving the
column or you give your X and Y AIS so
let's look at this one and this shows me
the data so we can choose plot three
this one we can choose plot two we can
choose plot one and we can put all that
data in one graph so that's when you are
putting in multi plots in one particular
graph you can always do a zoom you can
always look at the data right and this
is usually useful to look at the pattern
what kind of pattern pattern we see what
data we have and so on now moving
forward so we have seen how you are
creating these plots all in one window
let me reset this back to one plot per
window and let's basically plot time
series in a single year so what we have
seen is that when you look at the plot
method it was quite crowded then we
looked at solar and wind and if you
compare that you will see your
consumption pattern your solar pattern
your wind pattern and basically we can
see from this particular data some kind
of pattern so electricity consumption is
highest in the
winter where we will see what is the
consumption is it highest in Winter or
is it in summer we can see that by
breaking a year further into months we
can see that but we see a pattern which
goes for every year or every two years
being highest at a particular point of
time and then it drops down so
electricity consumption is highest in
Winter and that might be due to
electrical Heating and increase lighting
usage and lowest in summer now when you
look at electricity consumption appears
to split into two clusters we can always
look at the consumption one with
oscillation centered roundly around
1,400 gaws so you can always look at,
1400 gws and you see all the values here
which are in that particular consumption
another with fewer and more scattered
data points Cally roughed around 150 so
if you really expand this you can see
you will have lot of data points at this
point now we might guess that these
clusters correspond with weekdays and
weekends which we can see if you break
that data into yearly monthly weekly and
so on now if you look at solar
production that is highest in summer
when sunlight is most abundant and
lowest in winter so obviously when
you're making or gathering some insights
when you're looking at the data you are
also using your domain knowledge your
business knowledge your you know
knowledge of business to understand how
this goes if you look at wind power
production that's again highest in
Winters and drops down in summer so due
to stronger winds and more frequent
storms and lowest in summer so there is
some kind of increasing Trend in wind
power production over years which we can
see here over the years and all the time
series data what we are looking at is
referring or showing us some kind of
seasonality that is we are looking at
seasonality in which a pattern is
repeating again and again at regular
times at regular intervals so if you
look at consumption solar and wind time
series that oscillates between high and
low values on a yearly time scale which
we can break down and see I'll show you
that it corresponds with the seasonal
changes in weather over the year so
seasonality does not have to correspond
with meteorological reasons for example
if you look at retail stale sales data
uh that will show you yearly seasonality
with increased sales in particular
months so seasonality when we say can
occur on other time scales so the plots
what we are seeing here they are fine
but if you look at those plots they
might show some kind of weekly
seasonality also so in your consumption
corresponding to weekday and weekend so
let's plot for one single year now how
do I do that so first is I will look at
my data
2 that shows me the structure it shows
me date which is Factor other columns
which are all numerics now like we did
earlier I'll repeat this step where I'm
going to convert the date column into
date type look at head of it look at
class of it look at the structure of it
right and then what I want to do is I
want to add
this as to my data frame so I will
create a variable called mod data and
this one will have as data and I'm
formatting the value of x which is date
time into month day and year so let's do
that and now you look at the mod data
which I created like modified data so
this is the format I have it is in date
type if you carefully see here and then
I can look at the head of it so it says
me mod data now we are what we did here
is when I said my data
3 so my data 3 we did a cbind and I did
a mod data which is going to add this
column to my other Columns of my data 2
so my new data frame is my data 3 let's
look at the structure of it and you see
there is this date column I can delete
it I can remove it I can let it be right
so that depends on our choice might be
we want to once our analysis done we
want to remove the mod data right so we
can keep both of them now let's
basically extract data for a particular
year now how do you do that so this is
some wrangling so I will say my data 4
let's call it my data 4 and I will use
subset function so subset will work on
my data 3 that's the data and what I'll
do is I will do a subset how do how is
the subset found so I'll say take the
mod data column the value should be
greater than or equal to 2017 and should
be less than 2017 December 31st so I'm
getting data for one year here and I'm
storing it as my data
4 let's get the head of it and you see
we are specifically looking at 2017
related data now let's do a plotting of
this where I will only create a plot for
one year so I'm saying my data 4 that's
my
new data what we got so here I am going
to take the first
column which is mod data I'm going to
take the third column which is
consumption so I'm looking at the date
format for one year consumption values
for it and then rest of the things as we
have done earlier let's look at the plot
and this makes more meaning right so
when you look at this plot it tells me
Jan to Jan it shows me some kind of
pattern where I have divided the year
into months right and it is broken down
into say two months so Jan and March and
May and July and so on but we still see
a pattern and that gives me good
understanding of pattern where I've
broken it down into months so this is
where you have taken time series in a
single year to investigate further and
this is what we see right now we can
clearly see there are some weekly off
oscillations what one more interesting
feature is that at this level of GRA
ularity that is when you're looking at
yearly data there is a drastic decrease
in electricity consumption in early
January and late December during the
holidays or probably we can assume that
this is holidays now I can zoom in
further and look at just Jan and Feb
data let's see how we do that and let's
see how we work by zooming in the data
further so to zoom in the data further
let's see how we do it now here we have
this my data 4 which is basically having
a subset right so let's work on this one
so I will say my data 4 which earlier I
was taking data three I was doing a
subset and I was giving the date but
this time I will make it more narrower
so I'll say my data four I will say
subset from my data 3 and I will choose
mod data column which we have modified
with the date format I will choose the
starting date as
1701 that is Jan and then let's go till
Feb and let's create
this now let's look at the head of this
so it shows me we have the data which is
Jan and then you you can basically look
at more on this now again as I said
earlier let's find out the minimum of
this from the First Column so that is
basically your mod data so let's look
into this one and that
basically will give me minimum and
maximum let's look at the Valu so this
one tells me Jan 17 January 1 and
maximum is
your Feb 28th 2 month 2017 so we are
actually looking at two months data here
let's look at the Y minimum so this is I
will look at column three now what is
column three consumption so let's look
at the minimum value for consumption
maximum value of consumption let's look
at the values which can be given as our
limits now this is the minimum and
maximum now let's do a plotting for this
data which has been narrowed down for
consumption based on my data so I'm
saying My First Column which is mod data
and then third column which is
consumption I'm giving some naming
convention for for sorry namings for
your xaxis Y axis what is my
consumption or what is my title here
what is the color and then you see I'm
using X limit to give the minimum and
maximum limit and Y limit so let's look
at this data and if you look at this
data it is specifically for two months
and again I can look at the pattern here
what I can also do is I can add some
grid here so I can basically look at
this data and make more meaning out of
it so it is bi-weekly data you can see
now I can add a line here using AB line
and then I can basically choose what
lines I would want to add
horizontally so that basically allows me
to dissect the data and look at data in
a more meaningful way I can also add
vertical lines so vertical lines is I'm
saying sequence will be minimum maximum
and and I'm saying an interval of seven
so let's do this and this basically has
added some lines every week and you can
see at the end of week it is dropping
and then it is starting again it Peaks
somewhere in the mid of the week and
again it drops down so this is you're
looking at your consumption data right
now what we can also do is we can create
some box plots so when we looked at
zooming in data for Jan and Feb you can
add some data points like like this so
consumption is highest on the weekday as
I showed you here and lowest on the
weekends so this is what we are seeing
when we are breaking the data or zooming
it further for a couple of months so we
have vertical grid lines and we have
nicely formatted tick labels that is Jan
1st Jan 15 Feb 1st and so on so we can
easily tell which days are weekday and
weekends with use of these grid lines
and basically breaking it down so there
are are many other ways to actually
visualize your time series data
depending on what patterns you're trying
to explore you can use Scatter Plots you
can use heat maps you can use histograms
and so on now moving further we would
want to explore the seasonality right so
when you further explore the seasonality
of our data we can use box plots
basically to group the data by different
time periods and display the
distribution for each group now how do
we do
that let's come here and let's see how
box plot works so I can just do a simple
box plot and I can choose my consumption
column and that gives me just the
consumption data but this really does
not give me any meaning I can look at
solar data I can look at the wind data
and we can also see some outliers here
so we can create box plots but if we
would want to do a box plot what is box
box plot it is basically a visual
display of your five number summary that
is you want to look at your mean median
you want to look at your 25th percentile
50 percentile or 75th percentile so we
can use a quantile function use the
consumption column and then you
basically give a vector which shows you
five number summary so that's your
quantile and then let's do a box plot so
if you are looking at quantile it tells
me what what is the minimum what is 25th
percentile 50 75th and 100 that's from
my consumption column so let's create a
box plot for consumption let's give it a
name as consumption let's give Y axis as
consumption and a limit for y AIS now
that's my consumption graph so I can
look at yearly data now that will make
more meaning rather than just looking at
the complete consumption data so how do
we do it yearly so we will say
consumption and then I will say the ear
column so it is consumption but grouped
based on ear so here I can give x-axis y
AIS and I can give y limit so let's
create this and this makes more meaning
we can give some coloring scheme here
but now I'm looking at 2006 2007 8 9 and
so on and we can look at the data what
is the range right it gives me 5% TI or
sorry five number summary of the data
per year and it basically allows me to
look at the seasonality of this
similarly we can create box plot by just
giving consumption yearly grouped and
here I'm giving the title as consumption
y AIS xaxis and Y limit wherein I can
also use lass so this is one more
feature which you can do and that
basically will give me The Tick points
if you compare this one to the previous
graph so when I created this previous
graph I had 2006 2008 and I had from 600
to 18800 and if I go for the next one I
am basically seeing more useful
information now let's look at monthly
data so I would want to group it based
on months and let's create that so this
gives me the monthly data where I'm
looking at months and I could select a
particular year or I can just do a
grouping based on months so I can have
multiple plots to see a difference here
so let's do this now let's create a box
plot for consumption which is monthly
data and let's give it a color let's
look at the wind data which is again
grouped monthly and let's look at the
solar data which is grouped monthly now
if I zoom in it it basically gives me
the seasonality of the data for your
wind for your consumption for your solar
so what we are doing is we are creating
these box plots which are giving us
values now what I can also do is I could
look at the day wise also but before we
look into this how do I infer some
information from these box plots which
are being created so this is what we
have done where we are looking at the
data for month and these box plots give
me year seasonality which we were seeing
in earlier plots but give some
additional insights so if I look at the
data here it tells me the electricity
consumption is generally higher in
Winter now this is based on months so we
can see consumption is higher in Winters
and lower in summer so we can obviously
look at our plot we can can see where it
is lower where it is higher and then we
can look at the median and lower two
quartiles are lower in December and
January compared to November and
February so that is you look at the
quartiles and you will see that the
median and lower two quartiles are lower
in December and
January here Jan and December so you can
look at from my plot
now this is giving you some idea on
seasonality now that might be due to
business being closed over holidays now
this one we were also seeing when we
looked at time series for 2017 only and
box blot basically confirms that there
is this consistent pattern throughout
the years now when you look at your
solar and wind power production both
will give you a year seasonality what we
we are seeing here and if basically I
look at the data so it depends on what
parameters you are choosing but if you
look at solar it will reflect the effect
of occasional extreme wind speeds
associated with storms and other
transient and since we are grouping it
based on months we can see this pattern
is quite evident every year now what we
can do is we can group the data day wise
so here let me again reset this to one
plot per graph now I'll say box plot
I'll say consumption which is group
based on day now we know that there is a
day column and let's give a y limit and
let's look at the data so this is where
I'm grouping the data day wise so you
look at 31 days and you look at the box
plot so this is where you are plotting
it on a daily basis so you can look at
the data you can break it down to a
particular week so here I have given day
and I have chosen all the 31 days but I
can break it down to a week and I can
look at the data so if we look at the
data per week or per day we can
basically infer that electricity
consumption where I'm doing a
consumption group by day is higher on
weekday than on
weekends so time series with strong
seasonality can often be represented
with models that can decompose signal
into seasonality and long Trend now this
is an easy way now how do we look at the
frequency of the data that could be
interesting to see so let me uh look at
say the yearly
data which we were seeing
here now let's go further
and here we have looked at data so what
we will do is we look at the frequency
now when you look at the frequency when
you talk about frequency in your data so
we have the modified date column which
gives me a frequency and if we really
look into the data that will tell me
that the data is on a daily basis so for
that let's look at my data 3 again which
gives me data and you can just see all
the datas data or dates are in sequence
so your 22 23 24 25 26 and so on I can
look at I can access a deer
package that is basically allowing me to
work in a better way now I can look at
the summary of this and for all my
columns I am seeing what is the minimum
five number summary date and consumption
so date does not show me anything
because this is not in a date format it
is just a factor but other things have
the F number summary so we are looking
at wind plus solar we are looking at
year and month and day and all these
columns now what we will do is we will
want to find out the sum of each column
how many entries does it have and we
will say the value should na value
should not be considered so let's look
at this one so it tells me for my
particular columns so let me run this
again
and that shows me for each column how
many values you have and these counts do
not include the na values now similarly
I can find out specifically for
consumption I can find out is there any
na value so I'm saying is Na and let's
find out if there is any na value or
missing value in consumption it says
zero okay that's good if you look in
wind it tells me there are
1,463 entries which are na similarly
solar similarly wind do solar or wind
plus solar so it gives me a count of Na
values that is missing values and also
values which are not missing so to
understand frequency what we can do is
we can find out the minimum on the date
that is the First Column and I'm saying
RM na. RM is true that is get rid of Na
values and find out the minimum and
let's look at the minimum value this is
the minimum from my modified date now if
I would want to get the frequency I can
basically use sequence function so I can
say from X minimum that is the minimum
value I want to look at the frequency
that is day wise and let's just look at
five entries and see if there is a day
by byday frequency so let's look at the
value of this and obviously it tells me
there is day wise frequency so that
allows me to look at the frequency look
at the type of it it is an integer class
is a date so similarly we can say from X
minimum we can basically look at the
frequency month-wise
and I can again look at five records so
that shows me monthly data right so I
can
extract the data for frequency similarly
yearly data and that's also very useful
now we can select data which has na
values for wind so how do I do it I
would want to find out the wind column
and I want to find out where the values
are n a so I will create a variable and
here I will say my data three and then I
give a conditional where I say is na
in the column so let's do this now once
I've done this once I've done this I
have said that my selected win data from
my data 3 where we said na values and I
will give the names to this so names
should be in my data 3 I'm interested in
mod data consumption wind and solar so
these are the four columns I'm
interested in let's look at first 10
records here or first 10 rows so that
tells me these are the values where wind
has na or missing
values I can always do a view and that
gives me the complete data so it
basically shows me, 1463
entries and here it shows me all na
values so you can look at all the way to
the end and it shows me wind has na
solar does have some value here in the
last row but then also if you see the
numbers
have a difference so you have 1461 and
then you have 2174 so there is a
difference so there is some data in
between where wind has some values so we
have found out na values now what we
will do is we will select data which
does not have any values so I will call
it cell selected wi two I'll again use
my data 3 I will say which but now I'm
saying not na from this column and I
will select the data for the columns so
I'm interested in looking at 10 records
and this shows me not any values so no
more missing values so if I really look
at this data as I saw earlier which has
Na and if I look at these values which
are not na for the wind column so
looking at these two result we will know
that in year 2011 wind
column has some missing
values so let's focus on year 2011 so
how do I do that let's call it a
different variable I'll say my data 3 I
will say here when I say which where we
were saying na here I will say the year
should have a value of 2011 and I want
all these
columns let's look at the data here and
this is showing me 2011 but we are not
seeing all the values so there are some
values but then there are some missing
values also for 2011 based on whatever
analysis we have done so let's look at
the class of this it is basically a data
frame do a view and this one will help
me in finding out where are the na value
so if you just scroll down looking at
all the data let's search if wind column
has a na or a missing value and I will
see if there is any missing value in
which column or which row it is for the
wind column so we have all the values
which are
existing I could select and search for
one specific value and I'll show you how
we can do that so here let's scroll all
the way down so it's like you're
exploring your data and seeing
is wind column having na or missing
value for a particular row and let's
scroll here and here you see there is a
missing value for one particular row so
13th December 2011 has wind value 15
December has wind value but your 14th
December does not have right similarly
we can search so there was only one
entry which was missing now that could
be for some reason might be it was not
calculated mightbe it was not tabulated
so we have a missing value and that can
affect my plotting that can affect my
analysis so let's look at the number of
rows in this which will tell me how many
rows we have for 2011 so it tells me 365
so that is basically the number of days
in a year now we will find out if there
were na values so we earlier checked
total number of Na values per
column that is in your row number 265 to
269 we can see here 265 2 269
so this is where we were seeing are
there any na values right so let's go
back
here and we want to find out the number
of Na values for a particular year how
do I do it so I can just do a sum I will
say is na now I'm interested in my data
three wind column and I'm saying my ear
has to be 2011 but I'm finding out the
na
values so let's do this and it tells me
one and that's right that's what we saw
when we did a view let's see how many
non na values you have and that is 364
so that
basically satisfies my logic so it's 364
+ 1 missing so there are 365 let's look
at the structure of this it tells me you
have modified date and date format you
have consumption wind and solar now
let's create a variable selected wind
for 4 I will say wind three that is
which was having all my Na and non na
values for 2011 I will say let's find
out the na value because I'm interested
in finding out that particular row so
I'm saying find out where the value is
na a and I want all the columns let's
look at this one and this is my specific
row which has a na value
now we know that data follows a day wise
frequency which we have clearly seen now
let's select data which has Na and non
na values so let's say let's call it
test one I will use wind 3 which has Na
and Nonna values but now I will say I
want the modified date which should be
greater than
122 2001 now remember we had when we
were doing a view we saw that one
particular or what we see here 14th of
December there is no date so I will
select a subset of data which includes
This na and non na that is might be I
can take 13th of December and 15th of
December so let's start from 12 12 so
the date should be greater than 1212
that means 13th and it should be less
than 16 so that is 15th and the columns
right so now we have some data let's
look at this so I have have a I've
selected a subset of data I could have
done this using subset also so I have Na
and Nonna values now why are we doing
this so sometimes you might have some
data for a particular column and you may
want to find out if there are any
missing values might be you want to fill
them up or replace them with something
so that is usually useful when you are
doing a trend detection so say for
example you have data for every month
and might be in one one of the months
you have missed or might be you have
data for every year collected monthly
and then in one of the years for couple
of months you don't have the data like I
can say 2016 I have data for all 12
months 2017 all 12 months 2018 might be
I don't have data for March and June
2019 I don't have data for same months
so I can forward fill or backward fill
them using the previous year same month
data so we can do that so here I have
test data where I've extracted a subset
of data I can look at the class of this
it is a data frame structure of this it
has the columns now let's use the
library and function and use the Tidy r
package and what we will do is we will
fill it up so I will use test one I will
fill the wind column which has a missing
value now once you do this if you notice
it has done a forward fill so it has
taken the previous value and it has just
filled up that so you can fill up the
data using different directions such as
up and down left and right and so on so
we can take care of missing values in
our frequency data which allows us to
basically analyze the data in a better
way now here we will want to also look
look at some more data so this is to
deal with frequency so fill column
wherein you can take care of missing
values forward fill so filling values
can be done in different directions as I
said and you may want to First convert
your time series to specified frequency
if your data does not have a frequency
but we had now if you do not have a
frequency might be you can convert it
into a frequency such as weekly daily
monthly as I show show you and then
basically you can do a forward fill for
the values so for example if I have my
data I can break it down into weekly and
then look at the values and if there are
any values missing for weekly data I can
use a forward fill so that can take care
of my frequency data then let's look at
the trends of the data which is the last
part of this project so basically let's
look at the trend So when you say Trend
what does that mean so so in Time series
data you always have some kind of trend
so that will exhibit some slow gradual
variability in addition to higher
frequency variability such as
seasonality and noise now to visualize
these Trends what we do is we use what
we call as rolling means so we know how
our data is spread over year or month or
day but how about looking at a rolling
average and see what is the difference
so a rolling mean will tend to smooth a
Time series by averaging out the
variations and
frequencies so this can be higher than
the window size so there is something
called as windowing where you can choose
a set of time frame you can also average
out any seasonality on a time scale
equal to window size so this will allow
you to look at lower frequency variation
in the data so when we are looking at a
electricity consumption time series we
already saw there is a weekly pattern
there is a yearly seasonality which we
saw using box plots so we can also look
at the rolling means of the time scales
how do we do that so for this you can
use some package like zoo and then you
can basically use a rolling mean using
the zoo package and you can say what is
the frequency with which you want to
calculate the rolling mean now how do we
do this let's look at this data so here
I'm going to my look at my data three
which we have been using so far now
let's call it a 3-day test you can give
it any name I'm going to use my data 3
I'm using the PIP in
function now I will use deer and I will
arrange the data descending in ear now
you can always break it down step by
step and you can see the result of this
so I'm going to arrange this data in
descending order of year so obviously my
last one 2017 or 2018 will be on the top
you want to group the data by year so it
depends on how many years we have we'll
see so you can group the data by ear now
this data is then used to basically
mutate so mutate function is going to
allow me to use this rolling mean so
I'll call it as says 03 day so I'm going
to calculate a rolling mean every 3 days
for my consumption column and basically
let's ungroup this so let's see how this
works sorry yeah let's look at this and
here when I'm doing a 3-day test let's
look at the result of this and then I'll
explain this so if you see here we have
the test 3-day column now this has the
rolling average now what does that mean
so first value here what we see is
1367 is the average consumption in
2017 from the first date with a data
point on either side of it that is you
can look at this date so 11 13 0 then
you look
at you're looking at the value 1367 here
so you look at 1 13 0
1441 1530 if I take a mean of these so
for example if I would just do this
part and that is giving me mean okay
because I have a comment so let's
basically add anything as comment and
then let's do this so it saves me 1367
that's what we are seeing here right so
you're got getting a rolling average
every three days similarly if you want
every five days it takes the five values
and it gets the mid value right so you
can always find out the mean rolling
mean for for a particular frequency now
let's do that for 7 days that is weekly
data and yearly data that is 365 days so
how do I do it same logic my data test
now I'm using my data 3 I'm arranging it
in a descending order I'm grouping by
year so when you do a group by year so
earlier when we did a grouping by and
when we looked at the data it was
telling me how many rows we had right so
let's do a grouping by year and and
let's say test 07 so that's a rolling
average every 7 days and I'm also saying
take care of the na values similarly I'm
getting rolling average every 365 days
might be you can do quarterly might be
you can do half yearly and let's do this
so let's create this my data test and
let's look at the result of this so I
will use my data test I will say arrange
based on modified date now we know there
is a column called modified date I want
to just look at 2017 data so I'm doing a
filter right and then I will choose what
are the columns I'm interested in so I
will look at the seven and 365 day and
let's look at say first seven records so
let's do this and that basically gives
me the consumption value modified date
year and my rolling 7day average or
7-Day mean which is for first s days and
then 365 you will not see the data here
but if I do a view on this I can
basically see the values so you can
always select a particular column to see
the
values these are the values for every
7day rolling average this is for 365
days every 365 days so you see all the
values are missing but every 365 entry
you will have basically some data now
let's do a plotting of this this and
basically visualize this data which we
are seeing rolling average so let me
first do a plotting one plot per graph
and let's do a plotting I will take
consumption
data x-axis y AIS color and give a title
to this so let's create this and that's
my consumption data which is spread over
a period of time and that's fair enough
but now let's add some more plot to this
so I will add the 7day rolling average
to this so for second plot to be added
in the same one in R you can use points
so I will say points I will choose seven
data column type is line width x limit y
limit and color so let's do this and
that's my pattern 7day rolling average
which basically gives me some kind of
trend similarly I can add one more here
and this time I will choose the 365 day
and look at the pattern lines so now you
see some Dots here well you could do it
in a different way so I can just add
Legend to this and I can say Legend will
be where in x- axis and y axis so I'm
saying it will be
2,500 and Y is 1,800 so my Legend will
come in somewhere here I'm saying my
Legend will have consumption test and
this one I can give some names I can
give what is the color I can say what
kind of Legend it explains what is for
each color and then basically a vector
so let's add a legend to this and I've
added a legend now you can do a zoom and
look at the
data and here I see that uh my x- Axis
is fine but Y axis is going a little
about of my plotting area so I can
actually change that so here I have
1,800 how about making it
1,600 and let's look at this one so we
can
basically uh go for this one and start
again here plot and points and line and
then add a legend right and you can
basically place your Legend anywhere in
the plot so this basically is giving me
me the trend what I'm looking at my
rolling average so similarly you can
look at the trend for wind and solar
data so what we are seeing here is when
you look at Trend this is one more way
of looking at it you can always create
plots in different ways so 7-Day rolling
mean has smoothed out all weekly
seasonality which we were seeing Here in
My Graph where you look at every 7 Day
preserving the yearly seasonality so
7day will tell that electricity
consumption is typically higher in
Winter and lower in summer so better is
you break it down uh yearly so here if
you look at every year you can see when
is winter when is summer what is the
seasonality what you're Trend what
you're seeing here and if there is a
decrease or increase uh for few weeks
every winter so similarly if you look at
360 5 now as you said as I said rolling
average basically uh reduces the
variation so if I look at 365 rolling
mean we can see long-term Trend in
electricity consumption is pretty flat
now that's what we are seeing it's kind
of pretty flat there is not much
variation over years if you really join
these dots
so we can basically see some highs and
lows and that gives me a trend now this
is how you can do a trend detection and
similarly we can do plotting for wind
and solar so this is a small project
which I demonstrated using R now all
this code which you have here in the
form of a project. r file you can find
here in my GitHub page this is the
document which explains some things feel
free to download this and you can add
details to it this is the sample data
set which you can also find in my
repository in the data sets folder so
continue learning and continue
practicing
R Excel is a really powerful tool for
data analytics and Reporting and pivot
tables are one of the features that
Excel offers for creating tabular
reports to summarize our data let's
begin by understanding what is a p
table a pivot table is a tool that
summarizes and reorganizes selected
columns and rows of data in a
spreadsheet to obtain a desired
report it does not actually change the
spreadsheet data it simply pivots a turn
turns the data to view it in different
perspectives pivot tables are especially
useful with large amounts of data that
would be time consuming to calculate
manually now let's understand the
different components of a pivot table so
there are four main components first we
have rows when a field is chosen for the
row area it populates as the first
column in the pivot table similar to The
Columns all row labels are unique values
and duplicates are removed columns is
the second component when a field is
chosen for the column area only the
unique values of the field are listed
across the
top then we have values each value is
kept in a pivot table cell and displays
the summarized information the most
common values are sum average minimum
and maximum finally we have filters
filters apply a calculation or
restriction to the entire table so let's
jump over to Microsoft Excel and let me
show you the data set that we will use
in this demo so with India being ready
for its 16th census in
2021 that is next year it is a good time
for us to analyze India's last census
data from 2011 and see where different
states and cities across India stood in
terms of population literacy and other
socioeconomic factors we will analyze
this data by creating different pivot
tables in Excel and explore some of its
features so let's begin first I'll show
you one of the features that Excel
offers us so suppose I click on any cell
and hit control+ Q you can see our
entire table is selected and at the
right bottom there's an option of quick
analysis now you can see by default
Excel has prompted certain features such
as formatting we have charts totals and
there's one more called tables now Excel
by default has created some P tables for
us now the first one you say sum of
district code by state names next we
have sum of sex ratio by state state
name then we have some of child sex
ratio some of male graduates and some of
female graduates by state name and there
are others before creating our pivote
table so let's have a final look at our
data set so First Column you see is the
city colum so there are different cities
from different parts of India then we
have the state code we have the state
name district code we have the total
population followed by male and female
population next you you can see we have
the total literates from each City then
we have the male and female literates
next we have the sex ratio then we have
the child sex ratio next we have total
number of graduates and finally you can
see we have male and female graduates so
using this table we'll create several
peot
tables now first of all let's create a
peot table to find the total population
for each state and sort it in descending
order so you can see here we have the
problem statement so our first P table
will have the total population for each
of the states in descending order so to
create a peot table you can click any
cell in your data go to the insert Tab
and here left you can see we have the
option to create a pivote table so let
me select pivote table now my range is
already selected the entire table and
here I'll choose existing worksheet
because I want to place my pivote table
in the same worksheet and I'll give my
location I'll point to cell Q5 now let
me click
okay you can see the P table Fields
appears here on the right now since we
want to find the total population for
each state so what I'll do is I'll drag
my state name onto rows so here in our P
table you can see we have the different
state names listed now we want the total
population for each of these states so
in the field list I'll search for total
population which is this one and drag it
under
values you can see we have our sum of
total population for each of these
states by default Excel will sum any
numeric column you can always change it
to average minimum maximum anything you
want now we want to sort this column in
descending order so I right click go to
sort option and choose Zed to a that is
largest to
smallest you can see here in 2011
Maharashtra had the highest number of
population or the total population in
Maharashtra was the highest then it was
utar Pradesh we had Andra Pradesh and if
I come down we have nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar Islands
towards the end so this is a simple peot
table that we created now the next
problem we have is we want to find the
total sum of literates in each City
belonging to a certain state so let's
see how to do it I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here I can click on
pivote table my range is selected I'll
choose existing worksheet and give my
location which is Q5 I click on
okay now here we want to find the total
sum of literates so what I'll do is
first let me drag total literates column
to values you have the total sum of
literates from all the
states next I want to see the sum of
total literates based on states and
cities so let me first drag state name
onto rows and then we draag City onto
rows you can see here we have our peot
table
ready to the left of the pivote table
you can see we have the state names and
the cities per state and on the right
you can see the total number of
literates from each City if I scroll
down we have Assam then you can see we
have
Bihar and if I keep scrolling we have
all the states harana Himachal Pradesh
that's Jammu and Kashmir which has now
become a union territory we have jarand
Karnataka and other states as well
moving
on okay so the next thing we want to see
is what is the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state with that
we also want to find the states that had
the highest and lowest sex ratio in
2011 so let's create a pivote table for
this I'll click on any cell go to insert
choose PBO table click on existing
worksheet I'll select cell Q5 and click
on
okay now since we want the average sex
ratio and the child sex ratio so first
I'll drag those columns either you can
manually scroll and drag it or here you
have the option to search for it so if I
look for child you can see we
have the same column listed can just
drag it from there let me delete this
and I also want the sex ratio
so I'll place it on top of child sex
ratio next we want to see it based on
different states so what I'll do is I'll
take state name and put it under rows so
here you can see we have our pivote
table ready on the left you can see we
have the different state names listed
and on the right we have the values now
we want to find the average Now by
default Excel will sum the numeric
columns you can see it tells you sum of
sex ratio and child sex ratio so what
you can do can click on this drop down
and go to Value field
settings and here summarize values by
you can choose average you can see the
custom name it says average of sex ratio
click on
okay our entire column is now get giving
us the average sex ratio similarly for
this column let me convert it into
average I'll again click on the drop-
down go to Value field settings click on
average and click
okay and you can see here we have the
average of child sex ratio for each of
the states now the next question says
which states had the highest and lowest
sex ratio so we'll consider this column
so we'll sort it in in any order you
want you can do it either ascending or
descending let me short it in descending
order you can see we have our column
sorted
now so in
2011 Kerala had the highest sex ratio
and if I scroll down to the bottom you
can see himanchal Pradesh had the lowest
which is around
[Music]
818 up next let's explore one more
feature of P table so suppose you want
to see the top or bottom few rows of a
pivote table you can do that as well so
here we have a question at hand we want
to find the top three cities with the
highest number of female graduates so
let's see from the entire P table how we
can filter the top three cities so I'll
go to insert click on the pivot table
option go to existing worksheet click on
Q5 and hit
okay now since we want to find the top
three cities I'll drag City column onto
rows and then we want the female
graduates so in the search bar I'll look
for
female and I'll choose this column that
is female graduates and drag it here
onto values so I have the sum of female
graduates for each of the Cities now
since we want to find the highest number
of female graduates in the top three
cities so let me first sort this
column I'll sort it in descending order
now we have it sorted now from this you
can say that Delhi greater Mumbai and
bangaluru are the top three cities but
it's displaying all the cities for us so
let's filter only the top three so what
you can do is right click and go to
filter under filter you have the option
of top 10 I'll select this
here I only want the top three so either
you
can go down like this or you can
directly type
three your column is already selected
let me just click on okay there you go
we have the required pivote table ready
and it only displays us the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates now the next thing we want to
see is how to use a Slicer in a peot
table so we have a question here What's
the total population for all the cities
in Rajasthan and Karnataka so let's
create a p table for this and see how
you can use a slicer to filter the
table click on existing I'll click on a
location this time
q6 click okay now since I want the total
population so I'll drag total population
onto values and then I'll select the
city on two rows and then the state name
also I'll place it on top of City so you
have in the pivote table all the states
and their cities and on the right you
can see the total population for each of
these cities but our question is we want
to find only for Rajasthan and Karnataka
now for that what you can do is go to
insert
and create a slicer either you can
create from this option or you can go to
pivote table analyze option and here you
have the option to create or insert a
slicer I click on this and since we want
to slice the table based on state that
is Rajasthan and Karnataka I'll choose
state name as my slicer
field you can see this is my slicer here
now you you only want the data for
Rajasthan and Karnataka so I'll search
for these two so here we have Karnataka
so let me select Karnataka
first and I also want for
Rajasthan so let me select Rajasthan
also you can see in our P table we only
have data for Rajasthan and
Karnataka so this p table shows you
different cities from Karnataka and the
total sum of population from each of the
cities and similarly we also have for
rajesthan moving ahead now we will see
another very interesting feature of
pivot that is how you
can create percentage contribution of a
table for example we have a question
here what's the percentage contribution
of male and female literates from each
state now we we want to see in terms of
percentage and not as sum or average
let's do that I'll create my pivote
table click on
existing and I'll select an empty
cell okay now here since we want to find
the percentage contribution of male and
female literates so first I'll
drag male literates onto values followed
by female literates on two values by
default it has summed up the male litat
and female lit value and also I want to
drag State
column to
rows so here you can see the sum of male
literates and female literates per state
I want to convert this as percentage
contribution so what we can do is I'll
select any cell and I'll right click
and I'll go to so value as and here I
have the option to select percentage of
grand total so I'll select
this you can see we have the percentage
contribution of male literates to the
total now if I sort this you will get to
know which state contributed or has the
highest percentage
contribution so we have Maharashtra for
male
literates then we had utar Pradesh
2011 if I come
down we had migala nagaland and Andaman
and nicobar
Islands as two states which had little
or minimal contribution to male
literates similarly let's do it for
female literates I'll go to so value as
and select percentage of grand
total so you can see here also
Maharashtra utar Pradesh then Gujarat
and all had the highest percentage
contribution to female
literates so this is another good
feature to convert your data and SE and
terms of
percentage now moving ahead let's say we
want to find the bottom three cities
from each state that had the lowest
female graduates we can do that as well
I'll go to insert click on
pivot go to existing worksheet select an
empty worksheet and click on
okay now since I want to see based on
States as well as cities so let me drag
the state name first onto Rose and let's
drag the city column onto
row
next we want female graduates so let me
look for female graduates in the field
list I'll drag it onto
values now we have the list of states
and the respective cities and to the
right of the peot table you can see the
sum of female graduates from each
City now first I'll sort this column
I'll right click go to sort and click on
sest to largest now we have sorted our
female graduates
from shortest or smallest to largest now
since I want to find the bottom three
cities from each state I'll come to the
cell
right click go to filter and select top
10 now
I'll replace top 10 with bottom and I
want the bottom three cities from each
state I have my column selected that is
some of female graduates if I click on
okay you can see here some of the states
don't have three cities so you can see
andman and nicobar islands has only one
city that is Port player while the
remaining you can find the bottom three
cities with the lowest number of female
graduates so Andhra Pradesh had these
three in Assam we had Naga then there
was diar and Sila similarly if I come
down in harana we have palwal kathal and
zind if I come further here you can see
for Karnataka there gangavati this ranii
benur and this skolar similarly you can
see for Kerala as
well now moving
ahead now in the next example I'll tell
you how you can create a calculated
field or a calculated column in Excel
with the help of a pivote table so in a
pivote table you can create or use
custom formulas to create calculated
fields or items calculated fields are
formulas that can refer to other fields
in the pivote table calculated Fields
appear with other value fields in the
pivote table like other value Fields a
calculated Fields name May proceed with
sum of followed by the field name name
so here we have a sales table that has
columns like the items which has
different fruits and vegetables and
those have been categorized as fruits
and vegetables we have the price per kg
and this is in terms of
rupees and we have the quantity that was
sold now let's see if you want to find
the sales for each item in the table you
can create a calculated field so your
sales column is going going to be the
product of price per kg and quantity so
let me show you how you can do that with
the help of a p table I'll create a peot
table
first click on an empty cell hit okay
now if you see on the top under P table
analyze and under calculations we have
the option Fields items and sets if I
click on this drop- down I get the
option to to create a calculated field
or insert a calculated field I click on
this I'll give my field name as sales
and I'll select my
formula I'll first click on price per kg
and hit insert field I'll give a space
hit shift 8 to give the product symbol
and then I'll double click on quantity
now this is my formula for sales that is
price per kg multiplied by quantity
I'll click on ADD and I click on okay if
you see here there's a calculated field
that is present in the pivote table
fields which is Sals but it did not add
it to our original table or original
table is the same but here we have added
a calculated field which is present only
in the pivote table list now we can use
this it has already taken it under
values now let's say I want to find the
sum of sales for each item
under each category you can see it here
we have our category fruit and we have
our category vegetable and under that we
have different items like apple apricot
banana similarly in vegetables we have
broccoli the scrots corn eggplant and
others so this is how you can create a
calculated field in a pivote table now
there's one more good feature that Excel
offers us and pivote table is to create
a pivote chart so you can use your
pivote table and create different charts
I'll show you how to do that if I go to
insert here I have the option of
recommended charts if I click on this
Excel gives me some default charts which
you can use let's say I'll select
this let me drag it a bit to the right
here you can see I'll close this pivote
field list this is a nice bar chart that
Excel has created this is called a
pivote chart now here you can see the
category fruits and vegetables and the
different fruits and vegetables are the
items in the y axis you can see the
total sales if you see from the graph
guava me the highest amount of Sals now
if I sort this let's sort this
first
you can see it here fruit guava meet the
highest amount of sales now since I
sorted and changed my P table the P
chart also automatically gets updated
similarly there are other charts also
that you can create let's go to the
insert Tab and let's click on
recommended charts again let's look for
a pie chart so this is a pie chart that
you can create let me click on okay so
here is our PI chart and each Pi
represents
a certain item and the P that has the
highest area represents it had the
highest amount of seals in this case you
can see it is guava and similarly we
have other items as well this is fruit
banana that's
corn and we have spinach and
others let's explore a few other charts
so first I'll click on my pivote table
go to insert and under recommended
charts let's now select a line chart if
I hit okay move it to the right so this
is a line chart you can see it starts
from guava which had the highest amount
of sales then it
drops and in the x-axis you can see the
different items similarly when it starts
with the vegetables broli made the
highest amount of sales with 2,800 rupe
and our lowest was eggplant plant at 900
rupees for fruits papaya sold the least
at 700 rupees let's take another chart
I'll go to insert under recommended
charts let's
see this time we'll see a bar chart now
this is
a horizontal bar chart and not a
vertical one we just saw a vertical
column chart like this this is an
horizontal bar chart now you can always
increase and decrease the size of these
charts let's explore a last chart let's
take the area chart for now so this is
an area chart again it looks similar to
the line chart it starts with guava
which had the highest amount of seals
similarly papaya under fruits had the
lowest amount of seals under vegetables
it was broccoli and finally eggplant
made the lowest amount of sales under
vegetable now let's let's go to our
first sheet and summarize what we have
done in this demo for p tables in Excel
so we had our
data this is a 2011 Census Data from
India we had the different cities the
state names and we had the total
population total literates female
literates male literates we had the sex
ratio total graduates and other
information so we began by understanding
how to create a simple p table where we
calculated the total population for each
state and sorted it in descending order
we found that Maharashtra utar prades
had the total population in
2011 then we saw another prevote table
where we calculated the total sum of
literates in each City belonging to a
certain state so you can see we had the
different state names and the cities
under each
state then then we saw another feature
where you could calculate the average of
a certain numerical column so here we
calculated the average sex ratio and the
child sex ratio for each state and found
out which one had the highest and lowest
sex
ratio after that we saw how you could
find or filter
tables we saw how to find the top three
cities with the highest number of female
graduates we found out that Delhi
greater Mumbai and bangaluru were the
top cities with highest number of female
gradu
next we saw how to use Slicer in a p
table so we sliced our table based on
Rajasthan and Karnataka State and saw
the total population for all the cities
in Rajasthan and
Karnataka in the next
sheet we explored another feature that
was to find the percentage contribution
of male and female literates from each
state then here we saw how to find out
the the bottom three cities for each
state having lowest female graduates one
thing marked that some of the states did
not have three cities for example
Andaman had only one city that was Port
player but the others we found out the
bottom three cities that had the lowest
female graduates finally we looked at
how to create a calculated field in a
pivote table so we saw how to create a
calculated field called sales and then
we explored how to create different
charts and graphs so this was an area
chart that we saw there a column chart
we also saw or looked at a bar chart
that was a horizontal bar chart
similarly we saw how to create a pie
chart as well in this video we'll be
creating two dashboards using a sample
sales data set so if you want to get the
data and the dashboard file that we'll
be creating in this demo then please put
your email IDs in the comment section of
the video our team will share the files
via
email now let's begin by understanding
what is a dashboard in
Excel a dashboard is a visual interface
that provides an overview of key
measures relevant to a particular
objective with the help of charts and
graphs dashboard reports allow managers
to get a high level overview of the
business and help them make quick
decisions there are different types of
dashboards such as strategic dashboards
analytical dashboards and operational
dashboards an advantage of dashboards is
the quick detection of outliers and
correlations with Comprehensive data
visualization it is time saving as
compared to running multiple
reports with this understanding let's
jump into our demo for creating our
dashboards we'll be using a sample sales
data set let me show you the data set
first so here is the sales data set that
we'll be using for our demo so this data
set was actually generated using a
simulator and is completely random
it was not validated though we have
applied certain transformations to the
data using power query features so this
data as you can see has thousand rows so
using the simulator we had generated
thousand rows of
data similarly if I go on top you can
see this data set has 17 columns now let
me give you a brief about each of the
columns so first we have the region
column so we have Middle East and North
Africa there's North America Asia
subsaharan Africa and others similarly
we have the country names from which the
item was ordered the third column is the
item type so we have different items
Cosmetics vegetables there's baby food
cereal fruits Etc then we have the
representatives name or you can see this
as the customer name who ordered the
product then we have a sales Channel
column so there are basically basically
two channels whether the item was sold
offline or online next we have the order
priority column now here C stands for
critical then we have H which is for
high priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have unit sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item then we have
the unit price column this is the price
at which each product was sold then we
have the unit cost column which is
basically the production cost for each
of the items next we have the total
revenue the total revenue is actually
the product of unit sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of unit sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally we have created two more
columns that is order year and then we
have order month now these two columns
were actually generated using the power
query features so we use the order date
column which is this column and
extracted order year and Order
month so first we are going to create a
a revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more we'll
create separate P tables and po charts
and format them to make them look more
interesting and presentable We'll add
slices and timeline to our dashboards in
order to filter it based on specific
Fields now let's create our first report
to see the total revenue generated each
year so we need to create a poot table
for this I'll click on a cell in my data
set and then I'll go to the insert tab
here we have the option to select the
pivote table I click on this you can
see my table range is
selected next I want to place my pivote
table in a new worksheet and let's just
click on okay there you go so we have a
new sheet where I can place my PO
table so first I need to find the two
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is I'll drag my order ear column
under rows and then I'll select the
total revenue column under
values you can see I have my pwo chart
ready now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to
2017 now based on this dat data let's
create our pivote chart so I'll click on
any
cell go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this now actually I want a line
chart so I'll click on line here and
select
okay there you go so we have
successfully created our first pivote
chart now let me show you how you can
format this chart to make it more
readable so first
let me delete these so I'll right click
and select hide all field buttons on the
chart so this will delete the buttons
present on the chart now let me go ahead
and edit the chart title so the title I
want is total revenue I'll type it
down by
Year all right next let's do a few few
more Transformations so if I click on
this plus sign which is actually for
chart elements we have some options like
to add access access titles chart title
data labels this grid lines Legend and
others okay so let's remove the legend
now you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me add access titles so we'll
label our xaxis and Y AIS
so here under
x-axis I can write it
as
ear similarly on the y- axis I'll put
Revenue okay now you can move a bit all
right
now let me select this chart Style
option and go to Colors
first here I'll select yes yellow color
okay and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this
list I
want this style okay now you can also
add data labels so I'll just click on
data labels you can see we have the
revenue for each of the years now this
is not readable at all so we'll format
this a
bit if I click on this Arrow here I have
more
options if I scroll down you can see we
have something called as number here
I'll expand this and under category I'll
select
custom now here we'll give a format
code which is a bit
different so this is actually a kind of
a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value is
greater than let's say 9 lakh
999,000 let me make sure there are six
nines here so 1 2 3 4 5 and six okay we
are good to go I'll close the
bracket I'll give a
hash give two commas so if the revenue
is greater than 9 lakh
99,000 I'll put it in the format of
millions So within double quotes I'll
write
M I'll give a
semicolon followed by another
hash and if the value is less than the
desired
number it should be 0 million let me
click on add all right right you can see
how nicely we have formatted our data
and you see here we
have added the new format which is in
millions all right now if you want you
can go ahead and adjust
the boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this now if you notice this line
chart you can make a few conclusions for
example if you see here in
2010 the total revenue generated was
nearly 175 million now this came down to
150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till
2014 it reached 195 million and after
2014 it again came down to 180 million
and the revenue dropped significantly
between 2016 and
2017 in 2017 the revenue was just 96
million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue by Year all
right
now let's analyze the revenue generated
each year in different regions so for
this we'll create another peot table let
me close this I'll click on any cell go
to insert
and select pivote table I just click
okay so that my pivote table is placed
on a new sheet all right now this time
we want the revenue by each year and
region so first of all let's drag region
to
columns
then let's drag the order ear column
under rows and then I'll select total
revenue onto values so here you can see
we have the pivote table ready so for
2010 you can see in Asia this was the
revenue generated similarly if you see
for
2013 this was the total revenue
generated in Europe and we have for
other years as well now let's create a
line chart based on this pivot table so
I'll select any cell in the pivote table
I'll go to insert and I'll click on
recommend charts from this list I'll
select my line chart and click on okay
there you go so we have our next pivote
chart
ready so on the right you see the
different regions that are present in
different colors let me just expand it
so that you can see all the regions we
have so in total we
have seven
regions and each of the regions have
been represented in different col
colors so if you notice this
graph for the subsaharan African region
in
2012 subsaharan Africa made the highest
amount of
sales now from the sample data you can
also tell that the revenue for North
America has been significantly low
compared to other regions similarly if
you
see for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and
2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales were at this level then it
significantly dropped in
2012 then in
2013 there was a huge Spike and then in
again came down in 2015 and so on so you
can make your own conclusions by looking
at these line charts now let's format
this chart so first of all let's delete
the field buttons present on the chart
and we'll
also delete the Legend all right now let
me just reduce the size of the
chart next we'll add a chart title
so
we'll give the title as
Revenue by
year and
region
okay you can also format the y axis in
terms of
millions so I'll right click on this
axis and I'll select format
access I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom and we
will use this format that we created for
our previous chart there you go you can
see our access labels have been changed
in terms of millions now so let's close
this and let me save it now you can
reduce the font size or increase the
font size let me just show you suppose
you want to increase the font size of
the chart title so you just select it
and from here you can either reduce or
you can increase you can see now it's 12
if you want you can make it 16 similarly
you can also edit the access labels also
by selecting the chart title you can
also move it to left or right or you can
place it in the center as well for the
time being let me just keep it to the
left all right now we'll see the revenue
and total cost by each region and we'll
create a combo chart for this so let me
show you how to do it I'll go to my data
sheet
I have my cell selected I'll go to
insert and click on pivote table let me
just click on okay all right so for this
I'll select my region onto
rows and
then I'll
have two columns under values the first
one is going to be total revenue and the
next column will be the total cost
column all right so here we have the
pivote table ready now based on this
pivote table let's create our pivote
chart so I'll go to recommended charts
and if you see below at the bottom we
have combo chart so this is the preview
of the combo
chart all right now let me just click on
okay there you go so we have a nice
combo chart ready here now the way to
look at it is the bars represent
the total revenue which is this
column now the line
represents the total cost so let me go
ahead and edit this chart a bit so first
of all let's delete the field buttons
all right and let's also remove the
legend from
here next we'll add data labels so I'll
click on data labels here okay so these
are the data labels
for the bars or the revenue column now
let's format the data labels in terms of
millions so I'll click on this Arrow go
to more options if I scroll down I have
number from here I'll select custom
and I'll choose my type that is in
millions all right so you can see we
have formatted our dat data next thing
we'll add a chart title so here I'll
write as
Revenue
by
region it's actually revenue and total
cost by
region before moving ahead let me rename
the sheets as well I'll write
revenue
and total
cost
similarly sheet three also I'm going to
rename it as
Revenue
by year and
region so this makes your sheet more
readable all right now moving
ahead next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart so let's go to the data sheet and
create our P table first and click on
okay now I'll select order priority
under rows and under values I'll select
total
revenue so this is a very simple pivote
table so you have your order priority so
C is for critical H is for high L is for
low and M is for medium now based on
this let's create a p chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and here you have
pie chart I want to select this 3D type
of pie chart and I'll click on okay all
right so we have our pie chart ready let
me just resize it and from here I'll
remove the field buttons and I also
don't need the legend so I'll delete
this as well all right now let's give a
chart title so this is going to be
Revenue
by order
priority now let's add a data labels
I'll check this
option okay now let's again format this
in terms of
millions so
here I'll click on the last option I'll
go to numbers under category I'll select
custom and my type is going to be in
terms of millions there you go let me
close
this I will just move this to the
center all
right now if you want you can change the
color of the text as well so let's have
it in white color as and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool now moving to our next report so
this
time we are going to find the total
revenue by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country so for this we are going
to create a horizontal bar chart so let
me show you how to do it but before
moving ahead let me just rename this
sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by I'll just put op which stands for
order priority all right now let's
create our horizontal bar chart I'll go
to insert click on pivote table and
select
okay so I want my Revenue based on
different countries so I'll select
country and put it under rows and then
I'll choose total revenue and plac it
under values so here you have the
different country names we have
Afghanistan this Albania let me scroll
down you have
Bangladesh there
are a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down we have
India there's Jamaica Italy and all the
way to the bottom if you go we have New
Zealand the Netherlands Philippines
Portugal we also
have
Singapore lots and lots of
countries we have the UAE United States
of America Zimbabwe and
others all right let me go up so based
on this pivote table let's create our
pivote chart so I'll go to insert and
select recommended charts from here I'm
going to select the column chart you can
see the preview here and let me click on
okay all right so here you can
see the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries let's go ahead and edit this
chart so first of all I'll
delete the field buttons okay and let me
also remove the
legend here I'll write
Revenue
by countries
this going to be my chart
title
okay let's format this chart a little
more so I'll click on this option and
we'll select a new style let's
say I'll
select style six okay and let me now go
under colors and we'll select the color
color of the bars so let's choose this
color okay so you have a horizontal
column chart
ready and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have
the
revenue
cool now let me go ahead and rename this
sheet so I'll write Revenue
by
countries and hit enter
okay and finally we'll create another
report which is going to be part of our
Revenue dashboard and this is revenue by
items so we'll visualize our revenue for
different items present in the table so
if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits the cloths SN
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these
items so we'll continue the same drill
I'll create my poot table on a new
worksheet and this time I'm going to
drag item type under rows and we'll have
the total revenue under values so here
on the left of the table you can see we
have the different item names and then
we have the total revenue
so let me just short this total
revenue from largest to smallest so you
can see here office supplies meet the
highest amount of Revenue followed by
household then cosmetics and fruits meet
the lowest amount of
Revenue I'll click on this go to insert
and select recommended charts this time
I'm going to create a bar chart so so
this is how my bar chart is going to
look like I'll select okay all right now
let's format this chart a
bit I'll delete the field buttons and
I'll delete the legend as
well
and let's edit the chart title so this
is going to
be
Revenue by items
cool we all also want to change
the color of the bars so I have selected
all the bars I'll go to my home Tab and
here let's say I want to select green
color all
right I've edited my chart a bit
now
let's make
it 14 and I'll remove the Bold
okay here if you want you can change the
font Also let's keep it in blue color
all
right finally let's rename this sheet so
I'll write Revenue by
items
cool finally now it's time for us to
merge all the charts that we have
created to our dashboard so let me show
you how you can create the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet and first thing
I'm going to do is I'll click on The
View Tab and uncheck grid lines so this
will remove the grid lines present in
the
worksheet next I'm going to insert an
image so we'll have a background image
on our dashboard so the way to do is
I'll go to the insert Tab and under
illustrations I have the option to
select pictures or insert pictures so
I'm going to insert
picture present on the device that is my
computer I'll go to desktop and here I
have a folder called Excel dashboard
files and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit
insert so this is going to insert an
image now let me just drag drag this
image so it covers a feren of
portion so I'll hit shift and I'll drag
it all
right so you can see I have successfully
added a background image if you want you
can
still expand this background image a bit
to the right
cool now the next thing
is going to be the title of the
dashboard so I'll click on insert and
here I have the option to select a text
box so I'll click on a text box
and I'm going to place a text box in the
middle and I'm going to name this text
box as
Excel Revenue dashboard
on
Sals
I'll centraline
it let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see shape
format here I'm going to expand this
shape fill and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select a font you can select whichever
font you
want let me stick to britanica bold and
I'll increase the size to let's say
30 all right I'll just
drag the text
box I'll make the text as white instead
of black all right so we have
our title of the dashboard ready now if
you want you can also insert some icons
to this dashboard so I'll go to insert
and I'll click on illustrations again
and select
pictures I'm going to
add this two pictures which is of a
store and a
cart to make it
look visually appealing so I'll place
the
icons here and similarly let me just
copy
it and I'll place
the cart and the
store to the right as
well all
right next
the idea is
to bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the
dashboard so let me
copy each of the charts and place it on
the dashboard so I'll hit control V to
paste
it and we'll resize this as well
all
right similarly let me bring in all the
other charts as
well all right so now you can see I have
added all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard so you can see here we have
our line charts our column charts the
combo charts the Spy chart and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring 190
million a little
below all right this looks fine
now one more thing we are going to do
is we'll remove the white background
from each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart then I'll
right click and go to format chart
area here on the right you see we have
an option called No fill so if I select
no fill you can see the white background
is gone now similarly let me also remove
the grid lines so I'll select the grid
lines and hit delete so you also removed
the grid lines from here now let's also
remove the white out line that we have
so I'll select this chart go to format
and here I'll go to shape outline and
I'll select no outline you see this so
we have our total revenue by year which
is a line chart and this is completely
transparent now now what I'm going to do
is I'll place this chart over a box so
I'll go to insert and in insert we have
the option to create a shape so I'll
click on illustrate ations and here I'll
choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle so I'll just create a
rectangle
here all right and now what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click and choose bring to
front and I'll place this
shape below it all right now the next
thing is to edit the shape so first I'll
change the color of this box so let me
select this blue color and and let me
increase the transparency so I'll right
click and go to format shape here I'll
increase the transparency let's keep it
to
25% or let's say 20% all right next
thing we'll just con convert all the
font to white
color including the access labels the
chart
title will'll
also convert all
the access labels to white color so it
looks better now we'll just adjust
our chart over here next thing let's
just remove the outlet
so I'll go to shape outline and I'll
select no outline you see we have now
formatted our chart let's just pull this
a little
up all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so for the time
being I'll just pause the video and come
back
again all right so now you can see on
your screens we have nicely formatted
our dashboard so I have added a few
logos for each of the charts you can see
the logos here so for Revenue by
countries we have a globe then if you
see here this is kind of a map or a
location similarly we have all formatted
the color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of
millions if you look on the Y AIS even
the revenue for year and region are all
formatted in terms of
millions if you want this you can also
format the total year by Revenue in
terms of millions so the way to do is
you can select this graph right click
and go to format
access here if I scroll down you have
numbers and under category I'll select
custom then I'll select my type as this
format which is in
millions and you see here we have
successfully formatted our y AIS
labels all right so the next thing is to
add slicers and timelines to a dashboard
now slicers are used to format your data
based on a particular column suppose if
you want to see Revenue by certain items
you can add item as a slicer and you can
view the
entire dashboard similarly for timelines
you can add date columns so if you want
to see what was the amount of sales or
revenue generated on a particular year
or a particular month you can do that
using a timeline so I'll select one of
the charts and then either you can go to
the insert tab and here you can see
under filters we have slices and
timeline or if you go to the pivote
Chart analyze tab here also you have
insert slicer and timeline option so
I'll select insert slicer here first now
it's giving me the list of fields
present in the data set so I'll select
country region and let's say we want
to know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four slicers I'll click
on
okay you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia this
Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now moving ahead we need to connect all
the slices to a dashboard so what I'll
do is I'll right
click on this option and I'll go to
report
connections okay so under report
connections you have all the pivote
tables that we
created you currently see only one of
the P table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables
so let me check all the P tables present
in this workbook and click on okay all
right now that we have connected one of
our slicers we'll now connect the other
remaining slicers so I'll right click on
this go to report connections and I'll
check all the pivote tables present in
this worksheet click on okay similarly
let's do it for the country slicer I'll
go to report connections and and let me
select all the pivote
tables and finally we have the item type
so I'll right click go to report
connections and then I'll select all my
P
tables and let's hit okay all right now
let me just organize this a bit so I'll
place my P
tables to the
right I'll just reduce the
size let me scroll
down I'll
add my region slicer
here
similarly I'll add my final slicer that
is sales Channel now in our next
dashboard which is going to be the
profit dashboard I'll show you how to
add a timeline
all right now I have arranged all my
slicers so let's say you want to find
the revenue that was generated for an
item type let's say beverages so you can
just select beverages here and all your
charts show the respective revenues so
you have the total revenue by year for
beverages only similar L here you can
see the revenue by year and region only
for beverages item type if I scroll
down now this chart represents the
revenue that was generated in each of
the countries only for item type
beverages let me just uncheck
it all
right let's say you want to
see the revenue generated for a country
like India so I have selected India here
and now you can
see my graph has changed only for
country
India you can see here it is showing
only for India
now now similarly you can also filter
your revenues based on the different
regions let's say you want to know the
revenue generated based on sales channel
so we have two sales Channel channel
that is offline and online suppose you
want to know the revenue generated
offline so I'll just select offline you
can see the values have changed so these
were the revenues generated for each of
the items only for
offline if you see here now these were
all the offline sales for the different
regions
so this is our entire Excel Revenue
dashboard on sales we created multiple
charts and graphs then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and finally we saw
how we could filter our data based on
these
slicers likewise now we are going to
create a profit dashboard based on the
same data so before moving ahead let me
rename this sheet as Revenue dashboard
I'll write
R dashboard
okay now we'll move to our data sheet
and start creating a PO tables and pivot
charts for the profit
dashboard all right so let me go ahead
and create my first pivot table
so I'll create a new
worksheet this time I'm going to create
a line chart to visualize the profit for
each year so I'll drag my total profit
column to values and my order year to
rows so here you can see we have
our pivote table ready now you can sort
this data to get an idea as to
which year had the highest profit and
which year had the low profit so from
this pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
2014 had the maximum amount of profit
and 2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do control Z to undo it all
right now based on this P table let me
go ahead and create my P chart so I'll
go to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart I'll click on okay let me me close
this
similarly we are going
to edit this chart now so first I'll
hide all the field buttons present on
the chart and I'll rename the chart
title as
total
profit by
year next I'm going to remove the legend
so I'll delete
this let's do some more
formatting so I'll go to style
and this
time I'm going to
select my style type okay and if you
want you can choose the colors as well
for the Tim being let's have this yellow
color next let me add the data labels so
again if you see here this is not
formatted properly so let's go ahead and
format
the data labels so I'll click on
number and I'll select custom
here and the type I'm going to select is
in millions and I'll click on close so
here you can see we have
our line chart ready which shows total
profit by year let's rename this sheet
as
profit
by Year all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again next we are going
to show the total profit by countries
for this I'm going to create a map so
let me first create my poot table so
I'll go to insert and I'll click on
pivote
table let me click on
okay since I want the country names so
I'll select country under Rose and then
I
have my total profit under
values the next thing I'm going to do is
I'll just rename the row labels as
countries and then I'm going to delete
the grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this P table go to
the design tab here we have sub totals
and Grand totals I'll switch off the
grand total let me just verify it again
I'll scroll down you see the grand total
has gone now all right now we want to
create a map out of this the way to do
is I'm going to select my
data copy it I'll go on top and I'll
paste it here using this data I can
create my field map now so I'll go to
insert here we have the option to create
a field map there you go
you can see we have our map ready I can
expand this now as you can see our map
has a color scale which comes from light
gray color to dark blue color so the
countries that are in Gray or you can
say light blue have the lowest amount of
profit while the regions or the
countries that have been shaded
in dark color or dark blue color have
highest amount of profit I will go ahead
and delete this
scale okay next we need to connect this
map to the original data source so what
I'll do is I'll right click on this map
and I'll go to select data here instead
of the previous range I'll give my new
Range now so my new Range will be my
original po table that I had created
I'll go on top and click on okay so we
have our map ready now now if you want
you can change the color of the shade so
I'll just go to colors and let's say
we'll keep green color so the countries
that are shaded in dark green have the
highest amount of profit while those
which are highlighted in light green
color are are the countries that made
least amount of profit okay now moving
on next
we want to create a pivote table that
will show us the profit by year and
sales channel so for this we are going
to create another line chart so I'll go
to insert and click on pivote table so
I'll select new worksheet here since I
want to know the profit by year first of
all I'll drag my order year column to
rows and then I'll choose my total
profit cost column under values next I'm
going to select my sales Channel under
columns there you go so we have our
pivote table here based on this pivote
table let me create my pivote chart so
I'll go to recommended charts and I'm
going to create a line chart I close
this you see here based on this chart
you can tell the profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit if you
Mark Clearly in year 2012 the Online
Profit was actually higher than the
offline profit so let me go ahead and
edit this chart a bit so we'll delete
the field buttons I'll also delete the
legend for now let me go ahead and add a
chart title so so I'll
write
profit
by year
and sales
Channel
okay so this is my second report before
moving ahead let me just rename this
sheet so I'll write
profit
by country
similarly let me rename this sheet as
profit by year and let's say SC for
sales
Channel
okay moving
ahead now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivote
table and click on okay so I'll drag my
sales Channel under rows and then we'll
have the total profit column under
values so this is my simple pivote table
now let's create our pivote chart which
is going to be a pie chart let me
explore the other types of pie charts we
have okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here I'll click on okay let's edit
this chart I'll remove the field buttons
let me now remove the legend as well
I'll just resize it and this is going to
be
profit
by sales
Channel
okay let's also
add data
labels and here again I'm going to
format this
label I'll select the category as custom
and my type will be in millions okay let
me just move
this to the
left and this to the right
okay let's also delete the lines
cool now let me just rename this sheet
so I'll write profit
by let's say see which stands for sales
Channel cool finally I'm going to create
a report that will show the revenue and
profit by items so I'll go ahead and
create my pivote table first this time
I'll choose my total profit under
values and we'll also have the revenue
column so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I'm going to
select item type under rows so here is
my pivote table based on this pivote
table let me now create a combo chart so
you can see the preview of the chart the
blue bars represent the total revenue
and the Orange Line represents the total
profit I'll click on okay let me close
this first let's remove the field
buttons let's also
remove the legend
here then we'll add a chart title I'll
name it
as
revenue
and
profit by
items okay if you want you can also go
ahead and change the color of the bar
so let me just
select one of these colors
okay all right so we have our five
reports ready that we are going to use
for our profit
dashboard next let's create a new sheet
and we'll get started with building our
dashboard so I'll click on a new sheet
let me just rename this as profit
dashboard all
right we'll continue with the previous
drill so first of all let's go to the
view Tab and remove the grid lines now
we'll insert a background image like we
did for our Revenue dashboard so I'll go
to insert under illustrations I'll click
on pictures and select this device I'm
going to have the same background I'll
click on
insert all right so you can see we have
a picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag
this a bit to the
right we'll adjust the size
also all
right now let's copy the title of my
profit dashboard so here you can see I
have brought my Revenue
dashboard and I'll copy the title and
the logos that we used for the revenue
dashboard I'll paste it on my new Dash
code let's just align
it in the
center all right the next step let me
now go ahead and edit the title so this
is actually going to
be
Excel profit dashboard instead of
Revenue now we'll copy each of the
charts that we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had profit by sales
Channel all this we are going to copy
one by one and put it on the profit
dashboard so let me just copy a few
now I'll paste it
here and later on we can make the
adjustment copy this as
well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales
dashboard okay so here on my profit
dashboard I have added all the
charts and I have aligned and reshaped
it so that it looks good I've also made
some formatting for example I've have
reduced the size of the chart
title now let me go ahead and show you a
few few more formatting that we also did
for the revenue dashboard first let's
remove the white background from all the
charts so I'll select the first chart
I'll right click and I'll click on
format chart
area here under fill I'll select no fill
next I'm going to remove the grid lines
so I'll just delete it let me close this
now we also have a outline so I'll go to
design actually format and I'll remove
the
outline next I'm going to
add a blue box at the back like how we
did for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here okay and let me
just select the chart and I'll bring
this to front and I'll move this
to the
back next I'm going to change the font
color all to White so that it's clearly
visible and it's more
readable I'll do it for the x-axis as
well okay so here I have my first chart
ready the same I'm going to do for the
rest of the
charts okay so now you can see here I
have formatted all my charts I've also
added a blue
background you see here I have also
formatted the V labels in terms of
millions which is actually the profit
similarly here I have added the data
labels this is for
Revenue some of the charts also have the
data Legends so here you can see the
blue color represents
offline and the red represents online
similarly here you have the Legends I've
also formatted the map as well okay now
the next thing is to make this dashboard
more interactive so we'll add our
slicers as well as timeline first let me
show you how to add a timeline so I'll
select one of the charts and I'll go to
insert under insert I have the option to
create a timeline so I'll
just click on
timelines so timeline is actually based
on date columns so since in our data set
we only have two date columns one is
order date and one is ship date so Excel
has only shown us two columns so I'm
going to create my timeline based on
order date so I'll select my order date
column and I'll click on okay you can
see here this is called a timeline I can
expand this now this timeline is based
on months now now if I scroll this
timeline you can see here I have my
order year 20 0 and I have all the 12
months similarly we have for 2011 then
we have for
2012 all the way till 201 17 now you can
filter this in terms of years quarters
months or days let me just select year
now so I have years from 2010 till
2017 let me just squiz this and I'll
place it somewhere here on the
right now let me go ahead and create a
few slices for my profit dashboard so I
have selected one of the charts under
insert I'll click on
slicer you can see it gives me the list
of columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region let me
also select
country let's say I
want the representatives name or the
customer's name and I'll click on okay
so here I have created three
slicers let
me first resize it and I'll place
it on the
right similarly I'll place the country
column
also then we have the region
slicer I'll resize this and I'll bring
it here okay the next thing we need to
do is I have to connect all the slicers
and the timeline to the P tables for the
profit dashboard so I'm going to click
on the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select all the pivot tables that are
related to
profit so here I have selected four and
I need one more which is po table number
10 I click on okay similarly let's
create or connect my region filter to
all the pivot tables so I right click go
to report connections here I'll choose
all my pivote tables which are based on
profit I'll click on okay let's do it
for the country slicer as
well click on okay and similarly I'll
connect my timeline as well I'll go to
report
connections and I'll
select all the pivote tables related to
profit then I'll click on okay let me
now go ahead and create another slicer
based on sales channel so I'm selecting
one of the poot charts I'll go to insert
click on slicer and I'll select sales
Channel and hit
okay so I have my sales Channel slicer
now let me connected to all the
respective pivote
tables that are based on
profit click on
okay now let me just bring it here all
right the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first so you see we have all
the years here from 2010 till
2017 now suppose you want to know the
profit that was generated in the year
2012 so I'll just click on this range
and now you can see our charts only show
information for 2012 so this dot
represents that was 51 million profit in
the year 2012 similarly you can see
here the profit by sales channel for
2012 from the map you can see the
different countries and the profit each
of these countries made in
2012 if I scroll down you can see the
revenue and profit by items now if I
select another year let's say
2013 I can just drag this to the right
and now you can
see our profit by year and sales channel
for offline and online you can see the
map or the line chart start for total
profit by year so in 2012 it was 51
million and then it went up to 54
million in
similarly our map has also changed now
this is a sort of an information that we
have you can click on this
and check the information that Excel has
prompted all right so this is how you
can use a timeline now as I said we
checked by years you can also see it for
months and quarters as well let me just
uncheck
it I'll send it back to the place where
it was and I'll reduce the
size okay now suppose you want to check
the profit made by different
Representatives you can select them one
by one let's say Adam
Churchill this is
the profit generated by Adam Church
similarly you can select multiple
persons as well now suppose you want to
see the profit by different countries so
you can use the country slicer let me
just bring this to the middle and let's
expand our chart a
bit okay so here you have
the profit by different countries chart
I'll just bring this to the front so
that you can see it clearly
okay now here suppose you want to see
the profit
generated in let's say United Kingdom
you can select United Kingdom so this is
the map of United Kingdom and it tells
you the total profit that was generated
in United Kingdom and Below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in United Kingdom so you
had beverages clothes household office
supplies you can see clearly office
supplies item meet the highest amount of
profit in United Kingdom now you can
also select multiple countries let's say
I want to know for France as well so
my map will change accordingly so now I
have United Kingdom and France selected
and the other charts present in my
dashboard change accordingly now I have
my country selected as India you can see
the map of India
here and these were the respective
profit values now one thing to note here
is this is actually not millions that
should be in K that is Thousands so
please mark this as thousand and not in
millions even for this this is actually
K and not
million all right so we have
successfully created our second
dashboard that is on profit let me just
resize this a bit and we'll place it
where it was
earlier
cool so we saw how to create different
peot tables and poot charts and then we
formatted our poot charts based on our
requirement we saw how to edit the
colors now let me show you one more
thing you can also change the look and
feel of the dashboard by going to the
page layout tab under page layout you
have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are with
the office theme now let me just select
another theme let's say fa it you see
the colors have changed and it
looks really
beautiful similarly let me try out
another theme let's say organic you see
our chart has changed let me just delete
this okay you now once you change the
theme the text also change a bit you can
see the slicers are in a different
font let me explore One More theme let's
say this time I'm going to choose
depth and this is more of a green type
of
color you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best all
right now let me just move back to my
Revenue dashboard and see how it looks
there you go so since we changed our
theme even our Revenue dashboard is also
impacted
so this is how it looks
now you can always go ahead and play
with different themes colors fonts and
effects all right so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart horizontal and vertical bar charts
and then we learned how to add slicers
and connected to different pivote tables
and we filtered our data to see Revenue
as well as profit by items by countries
by different regions sales Channel we
learned how to create a map and lots
more let's quickly see some more
examples of doing data analysis using
Excel and for that we can use some
inbuilt add-ins which can be added to
our Excel sheet so for example if you
would want to do a descriptive analytics
or descriptive analysis on your data say
for example getting your descriptive
statistics such as your mean median mode
and so on so we can do that and we can
use Excel for it so for example you can
if you are given some data say I have
temperature price of ice cream unit sold
and I would want to have descriptive
statistics on this what I can do is I
can click on file and here in file you
can click on options and within options
click on on addin now within addin you
have Excel addin which is selected here
so click on say go for example and that
shows what addins are available and you
can choose which ones are you interested
in so for example I have chosen analysis
tool pack and solver addin and click on
okay now that basically should add more
options to your Excel so if you click on
data so here you see data analysis and
solver and this is what we would want to
use to get our descriptive statistics
for these three columns so for example
let's say
temperature or you can even give the
names later once you get your
descriptive statistics so for example
let's go for data analysis and here it
says what are you interested in there is
a two factor with replication you have
correlation co-variance descriptive
statistics
you have histogram so let's click on
descriptive statistics click on okay now
this one basically asks your input range
so while your cursor is blinking here
also it is said grouped by so let's give
it a range so for example I will say say
temperature now if I do this and I have
selected The Heading just look at that
and now you need an output range so
let's just select this
and then you can have your cursor
blinking in here let's select sa Fields
here and this is where I would want the
output now it also said what options do
you want so it has output range we can
then select summary statistics
confidence level so I will say summary
statistics is what I'm interested in say
okay and this says input input range
contains non-numeric data now why is
that because we chose temperature The
Heading also so click on okay and here
we will alter the range so this one is
our range should be only the values
numeric values on which we would want
the descriptive statistics we have
output range already selected we have
summary statistics and now you can click
on okay and that basically gives your
descriptive statistics for temperature
so here I could basically given a value
for this so I can say temperature and
that's my descriptive statistics for
temperature might be I can just do some
formatting and that's it so that gives
me descriptive statistics for the values
here now similarly we can do it for
price of ice cream so what we need is we
need to basically
go for
data data analysis descriptive
statistics say okay now you need to give
a range so here I will change my range
to these values output range is already
selected now we are interested in
summary statistics click on okay and
this says output range will overwrite
existing data press okay to overwrite
data in range I will say canel no that's
not what we want to do we need to give a
new Range so let's select our new Range
which is here and now click on okay so
now we get the values which is for your
price of ice cream so again we can
basically select this and say price of
ice
cream and we got our descriptive
statistics for price of ice cream and
like we did earlier I can select this I
can basically do a merge and center and
that gives me descriptive statistics for
price of ice cream so we could also
basically change this now I can go into
data and I can go into Data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
know that we had selected this B2 to B8
and this one which is H6 to h19 which
would want to shift it might be two
columns up so mightbe I can just say H5
and I can manually change it to H 17 and
let's say
okay and we will basically get this and
I can get rid of this so I can have it
in the same range so similarly so this
one will have to be renamed and I can
basically say price of ice
cream and that's basically my
descriptive statistics for my price of
ice
cream and similarly we can do it for the
third column which is units sold so we
would want to have this now let's see we
can click on data we can click on data
analysis descriptive statistics so we
need to give the range correctly so this
time our range changes to units sold now
we we can also say labels in first row
okay if we were selecting The Heading so
let's do it in this way so in my range
in my range let me empty this I can
basically select this which we know has
non-numeric data in the first row say
for example I'll say labels in first row
I'm interested in summary statistics and
this range will now have to be changed
from from H to basically something like
J so let's say J and let's select these
values so that should take care of
things and now you see you have your
units sold you did not have to manually
rename it and you have basically got the
descriptive statistics so this is how
you can simply perform analysis using
data analysis here you can basically get
your descriptive stat ics for your
columns and then you can do whatever
needed formatting you need to basically
make your data look in a good way now
let's look at one more example of data
analysis where we may want to look at
the frequency of values or frequency of
values occurring in a range of values so
for example if you have been given
temperatures you have been given some
pin where you would want to identify how
many values fall into the range of 0 to
20 20 to 30 30 to 40 40 to 50 and the
easiest way to do that would be creating
histogram now histogram is usually used
for data analysis where you would want
to look at different variables or say
features for example temperature is one
such feature might be there might be one
more variable or feature such as sale of
ice cream and you would want to see if
the increase or decrease in temperature
affects the increase or decrease in sale
of ice cream might be sale of ice cream
is a is a response based on temperature
so it depends so sometimes you may want
to find a relationship between two
variables whether they are positively or
negatively related or you would want to
do different kind of analysis and in
certain cases we may want to first to
analysis on one single variable look at
the frequency of values might we also
look at the defects and for which we can
use something like par chart so we can
go for histogram and that basically
gives us the frequency of values now how
do we do that so we have already added
the addin which is data analysis earlier
so we can just use the same thing again
here we would want to create a histogram
so let's say okay now I have already
selected input range so if you see here
my input range is temperature which is
also with the headings and I have bin
range which is basically the range of
values so for example I can select this
and that's my bin range I am selecting
or the option labels because I'm using
the first row which has the heading such
as temperature and pins now we need need
to give a output range so for example
let's say I would want my data here and
that becomes my output range so you can
have a sorted histogram or basically a
Paro chart so if that's what you're
interested in looking at the frequencies
for your different ranges and here I'm
also selecting chart output because I
would want to have a visual histogram
which gives us the frequency and it's as
simple as this just click on okay and
now you get your bins so it basically
tells you frequency of values which is
basically 20 but that does not mean it
is only talking about the values 20 it
is basically talking as a range of 0 to
20 so we have 0 to 20 that is two so we
can basically say there is one 20 here
with the 20 being the maximum value and
then there is one more 20 so that's your
0 to 20 then you have 20 to 30 which
shows three values so might be in that
case I can say
26 is one thing then I can say 30 that's
the second one and then basically I can
look at 22 so basically this one does
not select 20 as the lower range but it
basically selects 30 as the higher range
so I do see 20 to 30 there are three
entries similarly we can see values for
40 and 50 and since we have selected par
or sorted histogram that shows in a
descending order what is the highest
frequency of values within a particular
range so that shows me highest frequency
is five and then you have three and
three and then two so this is how we can
create a histogram and we can perform
analysis on a single variable now as
discussed earlier as I said sometimes we
may be interested in finding out the
correlation between different variables
such as say here we have temperature
price of ice cream and units sold and we
may want to find out the correlation
between one variable to another variable
or we would want to find out the
relationship between variables are they
linearly related are they positively
related negatively related and so on
and for that we can use the
correlation of your data analysis addin
so for example you want to find out
correlation of temperature and units
sold and what we can do is we can find
out that using a formula so for example
if I search for something like Co
relation and let's search so there is a
function called correlation which we can
use and we can use this to calculate the
correlation of temperature and units
sold so for example let's select this
and that's the function so it says give
me an first array and a second array so
we are interested in finding out
correlation of temperature and units
sold so let's select the range of values
for temperature and then I'm interested
in finding out the correlation of
temperature and units sold so let's
select this and that basically gives me
a range of values it gives me the
correlation value which is
2859 say okay and that's your value so
similarly we can do it for temperature
and price ice cream so let's go
for correlation so that's the function
we are interested in you need to give a
range of value so here we are interested
in temperature and price of ice cream so
let's select temperature and then the
second array or list of values is price
of ice cream let's select that let's
close our bracket and here we have the
correlation value of temperature and the
price of ice cream similarly you may be
interested in finding out temperature
and units sold like what we have done
earlier so we can do the same thing
based on function so this is same as
correlation of temperature and unit sold
so I can get rid of this one now how do
I do it using the data analysis add in
so for that what what we need is we need
to go into Data we need to go click on
data analysis and here you have the
option called correlation let's select
this now that basically needs an input
range so we need the range now I might
be interested in finding out the
correlation between temperature and
price of ice cream and units sold so
I've selected all the columns here we
will say Group by columns obviously we
need to select labels in first first row
because that is basically taking care of
the first row is heading now output
range you can just give one simple cell
and that's where your data will start
from or you can give a new workbook so
click on okay and that basically gives
your that basically gives your
correlation of your different variables
and what are the values and we can check
these values based on the values what we
have here so we have basically
temperature and price of ice
cream and that basically shows me
96149 you have temperature and units
sold so you
have
that